[MUSIC PLAYING]
STUDENT 1: Hi!
This is Kelly,
and I have with me
my friends David, Matye,
Steven, Michael, and Sandra.
JONES: Oh my goodness, that's
quite a collection of students.
So where are you all from?
STUDENT 1: Well,
I'm from California.
STUDENT 2: New York City.
STUDENT 3: Toronto, Canada.
STUDENT 4: Kansas City.
STUDENT 5: Westborough,
Massachusetts.
STUDENT 6: Knoxville, Tennessee.
JONES: Quite the range.
You having a good day today?
STUDENT 1: I'm sorry, can
you repeat that, please?
JONES: Are you
having a good day?
STUDENT 1: Are we
Yeah.
JONES: Is this better
than the day you
got your admit letter to MIT?
STUDENT 1: Ooh, is this
better than the day we
got our admit letter to MIT?
That's a pretty tough call.
STUDENT 2: I would say so.
STUDENT 6: This is
much more of a relief.
STUDENT 5: Probably, yeah.
STUDENT 1: I guess
much more of a relief.
JONES: It's much more of a
relief because you got out?
STUDENT 1: I'm sorry,
say that again?
JONES: Because you
got out finally?
STUDENT 1: Well, because we
got out, finally, I guess so.
JONES: So Kelly.
STUDENT 1: Yeah.
JONES: Just give me one
memorable moment at MIT.
STUDENT 1: One
JONES: A person,
a thing, a course?
STUDENT 1: I guess I don't know.
Right now, standing
here with Sandra,
who I work with on the
ambulance, the only thing
that's coming to my
mind's the ambulance.
So hi to all the EMTs out there.
JONES: Did you save
anybody's life this week?
STUDENT 1: Not this week.
Did we save anyone's life?
STUDENT 6: No.
We didn't work this week,
I don't think we were--
[LAUGHS]
JONES: So what's the most
traumatic EMT thing you did?
I used to be an EMT years
ago in in New York State.
STUDENT 1: Oh, wow.
Wait, what was your
question again?
I'm sorry, it's really loud.
JONES: It's really loud
over there with everybody--
a million graduates.
What's the most memorable
EMT thing you did?
STUDENT 1: The most
memorable EMT thing
I did was showing up one
time to a choking victim
and finding him completely
out on the ground.
And I wasn't actually
involved with his care,
but I was involved with the
hysterical wife care, which
ended up being a lot more
memorable than anything
else I've ever done.
JONES: Ah, yes.
So MIT students save the world,
and individual lives as well.
So, you guys, we have
to close this now.
You want to give a big
shout-out and a thank
you to people who
are here today?
Each of you--
STUDENT 1: --shout-out and thank
you to people who are here.
STUDENT 5: What?
STUDENT 1: Shout-out and thank
you to people who are here.
STUDENT 5: Thanks
to all my friends.
I mean, I wouldn't be
here without you guys.
STUDENT 6: Thank to all my
friends, and my mom and dad,
who--
I wouldn't be here without them.
STUDENT 2: Thank
you, mom and dad.
STUDENT 3: Thanks to my mom and
dad for helping me get here.
STUDENT 4: Thanks,
mom, dad, and Eric.
STUDENT 1: And I
have to say the same.
Thanks, mom and dad.
STUDENT 6: I got to
thank my brother, too.
He graduated class of '99.
He's also the
reason why I'm here.
JONES: Have fun today, you guys!
STUDENT 1: Thanks, you too.
ROSKO: Now, the
technology that enables
us to interview the students
over at the Johnson Athletic
Center is the same
technology that we
use for much greater distances.
Last year at Tech Day--
MIT's annual alumni reunion--
President Charles Vest conducted
a particularly long-distance
interview with a distinguished
alumnus from the class
of 1989--
astronaut Mike Fincke--
aboard the International Space
Station, some 400
kilometers above the earth.
Let's see this
long-distance communication.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Mike, welcome to your reunion.
[APPLAUSE]
- President Vest, thank
you very much for your kind
introduction.
I'd like to check our coms.
Can you hear me?
- You can-- we can
hear you very well.
- When we were setting
this up with NASA,
we were wondering if
we'd be able to get
a good audio and video, and
I can see you guys great.
I'm glad you guys can hear me.
And I said, if anybody could
do great audio and video,
it's MIT.
VEST: Lot of applause there.
- I miss MIT, 15 years ago.
And everybody who is an
alumnus in front of me
said, you know, it goes by fast.
And boy, it really does.
And I'm sure I'll probably feel
that way after 20 and 25 years.
But the nice thing
about having time
is it's given me a little
bit of perspective.
And the view we have on
the planet from up here
gives me some more perspective.
And what MIT does
is very important--
the mission of MIT,
the way that MIT
goes about teaching
its students,
and the way that MIT's not
afraid to be world-class.
These are very important
things to the entire planet.
[END PLAYBACK]
ROSKO: Now, when the class
of 2005 were sophomores,
a good number of them took MIT's
renowned mechanical engineering
course, 2.007.
This is a much-emulated course
where students design, engineer
and build a machine that
accomplishes specific tasks.
All this hard work culminates in
an end of the semester contest
where students compete head
to head in MIT's most exciting
spectator sport.
We offer first a
retrospective look
at the evolution of the
course over the last 30 years,
followed by highlights
from the contest from 2002,
the year the class of 2005 were
hard at work as sophomores.
Pay close attention, and you
might recognize your graduates
among some of the competitors.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[BUZZING SOUND]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- 2.70 started long, long ago,
in a place actually not far
away--
in the basement
of this building.
We gave the students
a creativity kit.
- Inside the tube is a rod--
that is, the piece
of welding rod.
- And I was a graduate
student at the time,
worked closely
with the students,
and learned that for their
first design project,
it was really hard for
them to decide what to do.
- This is where the lanyard's
going to be attached,
and that will be stretched out.
- So the next year, we
decided that we give them
a kit of materials, but give
them a very specific thing
to try to accomplish.
- I'm doing that for
lightness to cut mass,
but basically it's for
looks and steadiness.
- And they got into
it immediately,
and that sort of got
the ball rolling.
And 2.70 began with a very
simple contest that involved
making the machine go down
a hill in three minutes.
- --down and just drill a big
hole to know until you're okay.
- The 2.70 contest evolved
to where it is today.
When we first started,
it was a simple machine
doing a single thing
while people watched.
And it was quite slow.
After a while, we had machines,
side by side, doing things,
so you could see
some competition.
And then we got
interested in what
happens if the machines
actually collide in the middle,
and compete for territory.
- Tie the knot, move it back,
replace it, set it in the sand.
- From that, we evolved
robotically-controlled things.
- Ready, get set, go.
- Oh!
Yeah!
Oh!
- And that has
become a much more
interactive, interesting
thing to watch.
But the most important
thing that happened
was the students took
on the challenge,
they competed like crazy,
but helped each other
in the process.
That, I think, is one of the
most important things about
2.70, 2.007 first--
the whole idea that you can
work together, but still
compete and help each other.
A shared environment, a
shared learning experience,
a great model for what the
profession of engineering
ought to be about.
- I first came in contact and
actually heard about it when
I was here as an undergraduate.
And Woodie Flowers
was my UROP advisor.
Actually, I was blueprinting
an engine for my pickup truck.
And I was kind of looking
forward to taking 2.70,
but I had blown my
engine on my truck,
so he actually agreed to
let me at that point rebuild
the engine on my truck.
So I was peripherally
involved, I was always looking
in on the class-- gee, that
looks like a lot of fun--
but never really got
around to doing it.
Always kind of wishing I had,
but vicariously living it
by helping my friends and stuff.
And then I graduated,
went off to work,
came back as a professor.
And then I taught
one section in it,
because the course has the
main instructor in charge
of the whole class,
where you're really
the manager or the
captain of the ship.
So if I recall, there was
a committee for a while,
and they were debating to
whom to give the class to.
And they said, well, the only
person who really should teach
is Alex, because he has
good taste in fashion.
And we need someone with
a good taste in fashion.
So they ask me if I would do
it even though I have tenure,
and I said, okay,
but let's go ahead
and involve the undergraduates
more in actually running it,
and that will be like a
whole army of people helping.
Those are the-- that
was kind of a birth
of the undergraduate
assistant arm of it.
And we've been having
fun ever since.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- The contest is
just a lot of fun.
- It's one of the best
classes I will ever take.
I'm sure of it.
- 2.70 rocks.
- 2.70 has changed a lot.
Now, it's remote
control, interactive,
lots of things happening.
That happened gradually.
- The real thing
that has changed
is that we gone to radio control
from the old days of a tether.
So now the machines
have a lot more freedom.
And it also means in
designing a contest,
we can put more things
into it, so it's
more like a pinball machine.
- At first, the
students were required
to do pencil drawing
of devices before they
would go build them.
And most of them wouldn't,
they just go start building.
Then we learned drafting--
computer-aided drafting--
and they use those tools
to help a little bit.
Now, we're at the point where
you can do solid models,
and tools are becoming
much more useful,
and students will
do that because it's
actually fast and works.
And we're getting
to the point now
where the onscreen dynamic
simulations are good enough
that you can actually use them
to get an insight about what's
going to happen.
- So the kit has
involved with the class,
and with technology in general.
We just give them
primarily raw materials--
sheets of aluminum,
bars of metal,
just gears, bearings, motors.
That's it.
We just give them the
most basic of LEGO bricks.
And then they design,
cut, fold, weld,
put together real
machinery from it.
- We always try to change the
character of the transportation
problem if there
is one involved.
One year, we had
putting a square peg
in a round hole, which
was a lot of fun,
and MIT students can do that.
That's probably a
good experience.
- So the contests have
not really changed at all
in the sense that they
are to provide a challenge
to the students-- that when
you look at the contest,
there is no single right answer.
No one can look at this and
say, aha, that's how you win.
- When you get to
the end and there's
four or five completely
different designs that are
competitive, it's a good sign.
- And it's fun, because
all the students are all
really excited.
And it's not just,
oh, no, a problem set.
Let's see.
It's like, wow, I'm really
doing something useful.
Wow, cool.
This is cool.
I'm going to win.
Yeah.
- In 2.70 and 2.007, we try hard
to make sure the students know
that they have the freedom
to try something different.
Just get your instructor on
board, and say, you know what?
I don't know if I'm
going to do this or not,
but I want to try
this crazy thing.
And that's okay,
because it's not
about winning the
competition, It's
about doing a
meaningful, good job.
- When I start the class off,
first lecture, I said, okay.
Everyone wants to
win this contest.
First of all, it's not a
contest, it's a celebration.
It's just a great geeking time,
get together with your robots,
and yow, going to have fun.
Because statistically,
everyone here is going to lose,
because your chances of
winning are only one in 120.
So like, chill out,
relax, have fun.
And when you're
having fun, A, you
will do better, and B, when
other people ask you for help,
or you see someone needs help
and you help them, you learn.
And the more you learn,
the better chance you will
of doing better yourself.
And that's true in your
professional life, also.
- And you compete like crazy,
and you get a lot of kudos
for helping other people.
One of the things that
teaches, by the way,
is that ideas are cheap.
The combination of
ideas and execution,
and excellence in
the whole process,
is what really matters.
So, occasionally, someone
would keep their secret.
They would say, this is my idea,
and I'm not telling anybody.
And they would do
that for a while,
and they looked up, and
said, wait a minute.
Everybody else has had the same
idea, and they chose not to.
Maybe this is not--
maybe I'll talk to people
about what I want to do.
[MUSIC - CHUMBAWAMBA,
"TUBTHUMPING"]
- When you're a student,
failing early and often
is a very healthy
thing to go through.
Because every time that
happens, pick yourself up, say,
I now understand something
that is very important here.
I'm going to use that
information go forward.
- If you don't fail,
you will never have fun.
The trick is to
learn how to fail,
and that's a very
important part of what
we want to teach in this class.
- It's also nice to have an
environment in which failing
is okay.
The competition is always
designed so that there
are lots of ways to go.
And consequently, there are a
lot of ways to hide your ego,
and you can try
something that has
very low probability of
working, but your instructor
will say, hey, go for it.
Later in life, if you have
not established a faith
in your own ability
to be creative,
it's really hard to do that
when the stakes are so high.
If you make a mistake,
you might lose your job.
So while you have a chance
to test your creative wings,
you better do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
JONES: Okay, welcome back.
How about you in
the cheap seats?
Can you see us?
Wave.
Way in the back there.
I'm the dean of
admissions, Marilee Jones.
Let's talk to some
more students.
Who do we have here?
STUDENT 10: Hi!
STUDENTS: Hi!
STUDENT 10: We're
part of the MIT Muses.
I'm [? Algie. ?]
STUDENT 11: I'm [? Taowi. ?]
STUDENT 12: I'm Fran.
STUDENT 13: I'm [? Nikki. ?]
JONES: Oh, good morning, ladies.
STUDENT 10: Hello!
JONES: So where are you from?
STUDENT 10: I am from
Lexington, Massachusetts.
STUDENT 11: I'm from Hong Kong.
STUDENT 12: I'm from
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
STUDENT 13: I'm from
Atlanta, Georgia.
JONES: Aw.
And, quickly, what
were your majors?
STUDENT 10: What's that?
JONES: Your majors here.
STUDENT 10: Oh, I am Course
6.1 Electrical Engineering.
STUDENT 11: I'm Economics
major, Course 14.
STUDENT 12: Course 8, Physics.
STUDENT 13: I'm Course 9,
Brain and Cognitive Sciences.
JONES: Okay, so
who are the Muses?
What do you do?
STUDENT 10: We are MIT's only
all-female a capella group,
and we like to sing.
Except that's past tense--
we liked to sing.
JONES: Oh, too bad, you're
going to be breaking up.
So let's see, can you
sing the national anthem?
STUDENT 10: The national anthem?
JONES: No, no, just kidding.
They're going to
sing that later.
Okay, can you sing
some MIT song like--
what about the Beaver Call song?
STUDENT 10: Oh, okay,
the Beaver Call.
Beaver Call.
Okay.
[HUMMING]
STUDENT 11: Okay.
STUDENT 10: Ready, go.
STUDENTS: (SINGING) I'm an
engineer, you're an engineer,
we are engineers all.
And when we get together,
we do the engineer call.
E to the u, du dx,
E to the x, dx--
cosine, secant,
tangent, sine, 3.14159.
Integral, radical, mu, dv--
slipstick, slide rule, MIT.
[LAUGHTER]
STUDENT 10: You guys
are great give me a hug.
JONES: Very good.
So you love the Muses.
So why don't you each
tell me something
wonderful and memorable.
STUDENT 10: Wonderful and
memorable that we did at MIT.
JONES: Maybe your favorite
hack or something.
STUDENT 10: Our favorite hack.
I don't know, do
you guys have any?
STUDENT 12: I liked The Lord
of the Rings on the Dome.
STUDENT 13: I don't know.
STUDENT 11: Me neither.
JONES: How about
something memorable?
STUDENT 10: Something memorable.
Well, we went to DC
this IAP and sang.
We went on a little tour, and
we sang at state representative
offices, at hospitals, on
the street, everywhere.
And it was really awesome.
So, it's been a fun time.
STUDENT 12: Yeah!
JONES: Okay, so quick,
call out to your parents
and say thank you.
STUDENT 10: Call
out to our parents.
STUDENTS: Hi, mom!
Hi, dad!
STUDENT 11: Hi, grandma!
Sam.
JONES: Oh good.
Well, thank you
ladies, it was good.
STUDENT 10: thank you!
STUDENT 12: Thanks!
JONES: We have one more
student interview, there.
Can you hand
yourself off to him?
STUDENT 10: Sure, of course.
JONES: Thank you.
STUDENT 10: Bye!
JONES: I believe there are
nine a capella groups at MIT.
Lot of singers here.
There's something about that
math gene and the music gene.
When one gets triggered,
the other goes on as well.
There are a number of
a capella groups here.
Theirs are the
only female group.
I notice they changed the words
to some of that song, heh heh.
And there's a mix, and
there are all men as well.
So, right now in
Johnson, if you're
wondering what's happening
to your children,
or your loved one,
they're actually robing.
And they're getting
in line, and they
have to stay in their
exact place in line,
because they're going to
receive their actual diploma.
MIT does this very differently
from other schools.
At other schools, you just go
up and get some empty case.
At here, you get
the actual diploma.
So they have to get in
line and stay in line,
and this is why this
is a big production.
How are we doing?
Do we have our student there?
Okay, who's there?
It's Eric Chemi!
CHEMI: Hello!
JONES: Hello, Eric.
CHEMI: Can you hear me?
JONES: Eric, where are you from?
CHEMI: I'm from Los Angeles.
JONES: So I think Eric and his--
your mom and your sister
here are today, too,
and they brought Los
Angeles weather with you.
CHEMI: Yes.
We should thank the nature
spirits for the good weather
today.
JONES: Ah, I know.
It's the great MIT
weather machine.
CHEMI: Hi to my mom, and
hi to Jennifer out there
in the audience.
JONES: So can you sing
the national anthem?
CHEMI: Say it again?
JONES: Can you sing
the national anthem?
CHEMI: Can I sing?
JONES: No, no, no, never mind.
CHEMI: Heh heh.
So Eric.
CHEMI: Yeah?
JONES: This is the most
connected student at MIT.
Eric knows everybody there.
CHEMI: Well, my connections
didn't go that way.
I got-- my tassel didn't
have a little class of 2005.
Everyone has one with 2005,
and mine didn't have it,
so I think I got a raw deal.
and my hat barely fits.
JONES: [LAUGHING]
CHEMI: So my connections
don't go too far.
They don't work at the coop.
JONES: Eric is a winner
of the Compton Award.
It's the highest award a student
can win for service at MIT.
So how's your day been going?
CHEMI: It's been pretty good,
just looking around, seeing
a bunch of friends, and
lots of people here.
It's a big crowd.
JONES: What's it like
over there, Eric?
CHEMI: It's chaotic,
but it's under control.
It's very loud, everyone's
around, and it's fun.
I'm running into people I
haven't seen in a while.
JONES: So what happens to
you if you step out of line?
CHEMI: I think you
get in big trouble.
JONES: I think they don't give
you that 2005 for your hat.
CHEMI: Yeah.
They're starting to move now,
I think. it's around 8:50.
We have to report
back pretty soon.
JONES: So give me just
one memorable moment
that you've spent at MIT.
CHEMI: One memorable moment.
CHEMI: My swim test
barely making it
on the last lap the day before
the first day of classes.
I almost didn't make
it, but I got there.
JONES: So tell me.
What is the swim test?
A lot of people here don't
even know what that means.
CHEMI: Swim laps in
the pool, non-stop.
And if you don't make
it, you don't graduate.
That can be the
hardest requirement
for a lot of people, I think.
But I barely did it.
JONES: So you had to take math,
and physics, and chemistry,
and biology.
And you also have to
learn how to swim.
CHEMI: Yeah, the
swimming is a tough one.
That math is pretty easy.
JONES: So what's the
square root of 79?
CHEMI: 79?
Uh oh.
A little less than 9.
It should be about 8.9
or something, right?
But I don't know how
accurate I can make it.
JONES: So what's
your favorite hack?
CHEMI: What's my favorite hack?
JONES: Yeah.
CHEMI: Oh, I don't know.
Too many good ones.
I'm not going to
pick a favorite.
I'll get in trouble
with my friends.
I know some of those kids.
JONES: Well, Eric helped us
admit the past two freshman
classes to MIT because he serves
on the undergraduate admissions
board.
And so, Eric, I'm
going to ask you.
What do you do for
the sheer joy of it?
CHEMI: Say it again?
JONES: What would you do
for the sheer joy of it?
Remember that question
on the application?
CHEMI: We didn't have
it, I think, our year.
JONES: I know you didn't,
and I'm asking you now.
This is your final exam.
CHEMI: That's a tough one.
I don't know if I'm
qualified to graduate.
I guess I can't
think of the answer.
I would follow directions.
I brought a water bottle today.
I don't think that
security is going
to let me bring it through.
Following directions might be
what I should try to work on.
After four years, I never
really got around to doing that.
JONES: [LAUGHING]
So what are you
doing this summer,
now that you're leaving?
What are you going to do?
CHEMI: I'll be working
in New York City,
trying to pay back MIT.
JONES: Okay, Eric.
CHEMI: Okay, thank you, Marilee.
JONES: Wonderful talk with you.
CHEMI: Great.
JONES: Have a good day.
CHEMI: You too.
Bye-bye.
JONES: Okay.
ROSKO: Now, here at
MIT, there's a program
in the School of
Engineering that
helps prepare aspiring engineers
for the realities they'll
face in the day-to-day world.
Unlike the Apprentice, where
only one individual is crowned
a winner, the UPOP program--
Undergraduate Practice
Opportunities Program--
aims to make them all winners.
Let's take a look at the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- UPOP stands for Undergraduate
Practice Opportunities Program.
It's a program in the
School of Engineering
that we have designed to help
engineering students gain
a better appreciation
of the engineering
practice, the workplace,
and to help them acquire
the skills they
need to be effective
and be leaders in engineering
practice out there.
- We have four phases
to the program.
The first is a 40-hour
corporate training seminar.
It's called the Introduction to
Engineering Practice Workshop
that we teach during IAP.
The second is a
spring seminar series
taught by alumni that focus
on career development topics.
The third is the summer
practice experience,
where the students do an
internship for 10 weeks
during the summer.
And then, finally, we have a
fall reflective experience,
where the students
come back and share
with other students,
faculty and alumni
what they've learned from
their engineering practice
experience, and how it relates
to what we taught them.
- I think in doing a program
like UPOP in the School
of Engineering [INAUDIBLE]
responds to that [INAUDIBLE]
in the sense that not only do
we have to have our students
strong in their
technical discipline,
but it is important that
they have an appreciation,
and have the skills and ability,
to deal with engineering
practice as they are
in the real world.
- The topics I was most
interested about in the UPOP
program were how organizations
work, what engineers can do
and what their role is
within an organization,
and what sort of factors you
need to take into account when
you are planning a business,
such as marketing, knowing
your customers, and working
together with your whole team--
rather than just
your engineers--
to deliver the product
that people really want.
- There is a little
bit of warming up
to do with the
people I worked with.
And I guess there
were some challenges.
They gave my project for the
summer, and on the first day
I finished it.
And they were a little confused
as to what to do with me.
But I explored around, I ended
up learning a huge amount,
and I had a
marvelous time there.
- It definitely provided a
different approach to things.
You think engineering, you
think private industry.
You don't necessarily
think the public sector.
People miss out on that,
especially MIT students.
They miss out on the opportunity
to explore other realms,
because you have these
great companies who
come here, recruit the
students, provide them
with great packages
for the summer.
So it's hard to turn that down.
And to have that opportunity,
to have some other opportunities
available, like non-profits
or government or whatever,
I think is a good--
it's a good thing
for MIT students,
because you need MIT students in
all aspects of life, including
government.
- I definitely see myself
really curious, and not just
being able to come up with
an idea, but marketing it.
Because I've seen
these companies fail,
and this company was on the
edge for a long time now.
And so now I'm really--
I really wonder.
I really want to learn
about what makes a company,
and what can really
make it great.
- I think that the
UPOP experience
has been very important to
my MIT education as a whole,
because it's really
helped me get
a perspective on the
technologies and skills
that I've been
learning in my classes.
While I know from my classes
how to get the right answer
to a problem from UPOP, I know
how to put together questions,
how to think about
an organization,
or new technology,
or about my career,
and really how to set things up.
So it's really
taking a broader view
and incorporating a lot
of different elements
from psychology, managerial
science, marketing,
pretty much everything.
And when I add my MIT
education to that,
I feel very prepared for
my career and future.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
ROSKO: So 2004-2005 was
a big year in sports.
So 2004 and 2005 was
a big year in sports
here in Boston with a Super Bowl
championship, and, of course,
the Red Sox won
the World Series.
Woo!
I'm actually a Yankee
fan, but when in Rome--
JONES: Boo!
ROSKO: Now, the 2.007 contest is
MIT's biggest spectator event.
But a lack of
spectators does not
prevent MIT students from
participating in athletics.
In fact, it's not
widely known that MIT
has more varsity sports--
41-- than almost any other
college in the country--
aside from the one
up the river there.
As this video illustrates,
at MIT, students
don't just sit in the stands,
they also participate.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- MIT sponsors a uniquely
expansive athletic department,
which features 25
intercollegiate sports, 40 club
sport offerings, and 42
intercollegiate athletic
programs.
- Athletics are part of this
notion of building a community,
and building a complete
individual's education.
- I certainly feel more
well-rounded because of it.
I feel that I've had the chance
to excel in different aspects
of my life.
- MIT has the largest number
of academic All-Americas
in the country with 114 since
the program began in 1980.
I think it showcases
that our kids are
doing exceptionally
well in the classroom,
as well as on the field.
- At the beginning
of each season,
the football coach
says, "Gentlemen,
the first priority for you is
going to be your academics.
Second priority is
going to be football,
and if your list
doesn't look like this,
then you shouldn't
be in this room."
- Nearly 60% of
our undergraduates
compete in organized sports
at some level on campus.
It's a good thing, because
I met a lot of people
that I wouldn't
have met otherwise
who I would see afterwards.
And I was like, ah,
you're on my IM team.
So how's it going?
How's your research?
- They don't exist
for themselves.
They don't exist for the alumni
to make the alumni feel good.
We have them
because they're part
of the educational experience.
- Towards the edge, roll
[INAUDIBLE] Out into the water.
Down.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- The crew boat itself--
this 70-foot boat--
is a micromanaged
system in and of itself.
You've got the
administrator-- your coxswain.
And then you've got
your powerhouse.
You've got your stroke, who's
your leader of your powerhouse.
And then you've got your
four and five seats,
who are the peak of your boat.
And then you've got your
bow, who kind of guides
you along in the little
directions, left and right.
And so together, you work as
a team to the common goal.
- They learn incredible amounts
about leadership, teamwork,
sportsmanship, and courage--
the willingness to take risks
and push their abilities
beyond what they think they can
achieve.
- I've learned to push
myself during races
and during practices so
hard, and commit myself
to a certain goal
unequivocally in a way
that I never had before.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- The MIT I knew in
the 60s and early 70s
had a proper
emphasis on athletics
and a tremendous
diversity of sports,
and really emphasized
participation.
That part hasn't changed.
But what's happened is there's
an even greater variety
of sports today.
- If MIT doesn't
have something--
be it a club or
organization or sport--
if two people want to do it,
they'll let you organize it,
and you can have it.
It's up to the individual,
but MIT will embrace that.
- It always has been in
the past and always will
be about opportunity for all.
- One of the things that
I think is particularly
striking about the
athletic program at MIT
is the emphasis on
participation in sports,
rather than spectator sports.
You don't see the
whole campus coming out
to watch the football game
on a Saturday afternoon,
like you might plan on
some college campuses.
But you do see an
incredible number
of students that are engaged.
Currently, about
20% of the students
are involved in a varsity
sport; about 80% of the students
are involved in
intramural sports;
and 100% of the
undergraduates are
involved in the physical
education program.
- So it really lets students
pursue their interests,
whether they pursue them as
an extracurricular activity
through their school
previously, or whether it's
something brand new.
- We've been able to make
major investments in facilities
and support services
that have enhanced
an already vital program.
The biggest single change has
been the opening of the Zesiger
Center.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- The Z Center--
that thing is just beautiful.
- It just seemed like the
MIT campus became healthier,
because people were more
willing to work out,
because there were
more facilities,
and they were nicer.
- The new facilities
had been made possible
because there was a
vision on the part of MIT,
but then the
facilities could not
have been created without the
financial support of the alums
who have come forth
to say, yes, we
recognize that that is
an important priority,
and we want to be
able to support it.
You'll be in there
lifting weights,
and your professor
will be in there
lifting weights also, or
something, and say hi to him.
Just little things like
that, seeing people outside
of the classroom and interacting
not in an academic way I think
really helps build a community.
- It's not just
about the classroom,
or just about the
laboratory, but it's
about growing as a person.
And part of that is working
with other students who
are participating in
sports, or other sort
of events, the arts--
all of which will carry forward
into their future lives.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
JONES: Welcome back, everyone.
This is like
breaking news, I feel
like I'm on Peter Jennings.
Anyway, it's time for us to
interview some of the families
here today, because
the point is that this
is all about our graduates.
So here, we have
several families.
I have our first family here.
So I want to introduce you.
MILLER: I'm Tony Miller.
This is Annette [? Taverner's ?]
parents, Manuel and Barbara.
JONES: Welcome.
So your wife is graduating
today, their daughter.
MILLER: She's receiving
her PhD in Speech
and Hearing Bioscience
and Technology
from the Division of Health
Sciences and Technology.
JONES: You are also--
MILLER: I'm also a PhD
student in the same program.
JONES: But she's
graduating before you?
MILLER: She is.
She's two years ahead of me.
JONES: She's a little
smarter than you?
MILLER: Oh, definitely.
JONES: So tell me something.
Her name is what again?
MILLER: Annette Taverner.
JONES: Annette Taverner.
Okay.
So let's talk about
Annette for a minute.
So Annette grew up where?
MILLER: In Miami, Florida.
Her mother is a Cuban exile.
Her father is from Argentina.
She's the first
person of the family
to graduate from college.
JONES: So the very first
person in your family
to graduate from college, and
she's getting her PhD from MIT.
Nothing like going to the top.
So here's a big
call out to Annette,
over there robing and
getting ready for this today.
So what-- why do you
think her interest is
in hearing and speech?
Is there any of
that in your family?
MILLER: No, but
she was originally
trained as an
electrical engineer,
and she was very interested
in communication technologies.
JONES: And how about you?
Did you meet her here?
MILLER: I met her here.
JONES: Oh my god, so you're
like a real MIT family?
We became your matchmakers.
This is wonderful.
MILLER: She not only
received her PhD.
She received her MRS at MIT.
JONES: Oh, her
MRS. No babies yet?
MILLER: No babies yet.
JONES: Sorry, I'm a mother.
Sorry, forgive me.
So tell me a little
about your daughter.
Tell me a little
bit about Annette.
What's she like?
MILLER: Annette is
very personable.
She served on many
committees here.
She's an avid trap shooter
when she's in Miami.
JONES: A trap shooter?
MILLER: Shotguns.
JONES: Shotguns, so
like, pull, bang.
Like that?
MILLER: Exactly.
Yeah.
JONES: So she's got good
hand-eye coordination?
MILLER: Very good.
JONES: She's nobody you
want to make mad at you?
MILLER: No, especially if you're
one of those little clay disks.
Don't do it.
JONES: And where
do you live here?
MILLER: We live in Davis
Square, Somerville.
JONES: Okay, so not
in the [INAUDIBLE]
MILLER: No.
JONES: Well, welcome to you.
I hope it's a
wonderful day for you,
and a wonderful day for
your daughter Annette.
MILLER: Thank you.
JONES: Thank you.
Nice to meet you.
Great.
So Tom.
TOM: Yes, Marilee?
I'm supposed to--
so the students
being honored today have
been at MIT during a period
of unprecedented
growth in student life
and learning programs,
resulting in the construction
of new dorms, new classrooms,
and a beautiful new athletic
center.
We recently produced a series
of short video retrospectives
where students talk about
their MIT experiences
outside of the classrooms
and laboratories.
Watch the screen, and you
might once again catch
a glimpse of your graduate.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- When I came as a
freshman coming in,
there's all of these
things thrown at you.
So many activities to do,
so many organizations.
- And that's what's really so
impressive about this place,
is that everyone is
passionate about something.
You just have to talk to
them for five minutes,
and you'll start
to hear about it.
- I think what surprised me most
is really just how much there
is to do, and how
many people are
doing that stuff, like there's
a club for almost anything you
can imagine.
There's enough people that
actually fill the club, too.
- We're about to perform an
opera made up on the spot
from Italy.
Let the opera begin.
[NON-ENGLISH SONG]
- I came here at MIT.
I was interested in
computer science majoring,
but I also like the arts.
My favorite type
of art is dance.
I love to dance.
I've been dancing
since I was two.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- I've been studying
mechanical engineering at MIT.
And during the time
I've been here,
I've been really involved
in the Hobby Shop.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- I came to MIT to major
in computer science,
but while I was here, I
discovered lion dance.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- What I also found
here is a passion
for service on a scale, which
is different from anything
that I had really been
able to conceive of.
- We're going to explain about
filter systems for water.
- I was a coordinator of the
freshman leadership program.
I've also done a lot of
work within the community
at different schools within
the Cambridge system.
- The thing that I'm most
involved in right now
is MIT African Internet
Technology Initiative.
- I play both field
hockey and lacrosse.
I am involved in a
sorority alpha phi.
- I'm a small group leader--
a small group Bible
study leader--
for Asian Christian Fellowship.
And I was involved in
MIT Cross Products,
which is the only Christian
a capella group on campus.
- [INAUDIBLE]
- The range is just so large.
It would take a huge
amount of time just
to enumerate the opportunities.
And in some sense, this
challenge for the student
is figuring out which of
those things they want to do,
because they can't
do everything.
They can't even do a small
fraction of everything.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
JONES: Hi, everybody,
we're back.
We're back with
the Mahoney family.
So let's talk about your kids.
So who's graduating today?
MRS. MAHONEY: 2/3 of our
triplets are graduating today--
Maya and Quinn Mahoney.
Their sister Brenna graduated
from Cornell University
last weekend.
JONES: So 2/3 of
your triplets are
going to be in the great
Court in about an hour.
So how come your other one
chose to go to Cornell?
That's what I want to know.
MR. MAHONEY: She's very bright.
JONES: He's mad at me
because we were not
able to get enough kids
out of his high school.
You teach there, right?
MR. MAHONEY: Right.
I teach in an inner city high
school in Washington, DC.
It's a public
school, and we want
to send our graduates to MIT.
JONES: Amen.
Benjamin Banneker, right?
MR. MAHONEY: Benjamin
Banneker Academic High School.
JONES: And so where did
your triplets go to school?
MRS. MAHONEY: Sidwell
Friends School
in Washington DC, where
John taught for 24 years,
before he went to
Benjamin Banneker.
JONES: You know, I remember
these cases very well.
I remember your
children's cases.
Oh yeah.
It's not every day you see
twins or even triplets.
So did they have a
good experience here?
MR. MAHONEY: They had
a great experience.
And our son Quinn was just
involved with the Time Traveler
Convention.
And we're anticipating
seeing some sort of prank
this morning, but we don't
know anything about it.
He certainly is not involved.
JONES: So he could
be someone who
knows people, who knows
people who have something
to do with hacks?
MRS. MAHONEY:
Could be, could be.
JONES: Could be.
MR. MAHONEY: Could be.
JONES: So where
do they live here?
Which living groups?
MR. MAHONEY: Even though
they have the same major--
Course 6-- they live on
opposite ends of the campus.
Our son lives on East
Campus, and our daughter
lives in Next House.
JONES: In two
different ZIP codes.
So how are you financing
three big educations?
Plus you said you also
have an older son.
Is that right?
MRS. MAHONEY: And
he's here today.
He graduated from
Carnegie Mellon University
with a Bachelor's
and Master's degree.
We had help from
the grandparents.
JONES: Help from
And would you have to hitchhike
here for the graduation?
Got no gas money anymore?
MR. MAHONEY: And we're going
to ask them to pay us back.
JONES: They better
get good jobs.
Do they have good jobs lined up?
MR. MAHONEY: No.
Our daughter's going to get a
PhD in biomedical engineering
at Purdue University, and our
son's staying here for his
master's.
But they will eventually
have good jobs--
good, lucrative jobs.
And they'll pay us back.
JONES: And they'll take care of
their parents in their old age.
MRS. MAHONEY: Hopefully.
JONES: So did any future time
travelers show up at the time
traveler convention?
MR. MAHONEY: They decided they
rather show up at graduation.
JONES: That's good.
Well, it's a
pleasure to meet you.
Thank you for sending
your two kids to MIT.
Any more at home?
Any other Mahoneys at home
we should be looking for?
MRS. MAHONEY: No,
no younger ones.
This is it.
MR. MAHONEY: But there'll
be another generation
coming in about 30 years.
So now that you guys
are empty nesters,
now when are you going to do?
Now that you're broke
and empty-nested,
what are you going to do?
MRS. MAHONEY: Well,
we travel a lot now.
We're not totally broke.
MR. MAHONEY: And at my school,
we do the first robotics
competition, which is co-founded
by Woodie Flowers and Dean
Segue, and--
MRS. MAHONEY: Dean Kamen.
MR. MAHONEY: --this is a--
Dean Kamen.
And this is a way in
which the influence of MIT
has spread through the
schools of this nation.
Robotics is just turning
kids into engineers.
It's just been a lot of fun.
JONES: So your kids are
really loving that, are they?
MR. MAHONEY: Yeah.
It's just been a great program.
It's an extension of Course
2.70 into the high schools,
same sort of kit that
we get, and it's neat.
We do it in the back
of my classroom.
JONES: Well, that's great.
Well, it's a
pleasure to meet you.
And we're going to get some
of those kids out at Banneker.
MR. MAHONEY: Thank you.
MRS. MAHONEY: Thank you.
ROSKO: Hello again.
Once again, I'm Tom Rosko,
the Institute Archivist
and head of special lectures and
archives in the libraries here.
And that was Marilee
Jones, Dean of Admissions.
And welcome to you all,
those just arriving
for the ceremonies that
are about to occur.
Now, most people understand that
MIT is a research institution,
and that new inventions
happen all the time.
And here's a look at the genesis
of a particular recent student
intervention.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I like working
on projects where
I'm dealing with
the smaller things
in life, the little things
that perturb you every day.
And this problem of
waking up in the morning
is certainly something that
I used to think about a lot.
When I was waking up I would hit
the snooze button accidentally
for up to two hours, or
even accidentally turn
the alarm clock off.
So this is just sort
of a way I could
include some sort of
playfulness inside technology,
and solve a problem
without adding complexity.
Alarm clocks are traditionally
very annoying devices,
and I wanted to
create something that
was playful and meaningful,
and that could sort of even
excite some laughter in one
of the most hateful times
of the day.
So I took an industrial
design course
at the MIT Media Lab that
inspired me to create Clocky,
and I came up with the idea
and just sort of prototyped it
for a few days.
And from there, I think
somebody picked up on it
and realized it was something
that everybody could relate to.
- Part of the goal of consumer
electronics research here
at the MIT Media Lab is to take
advantage of the intelligence
that we could put
inside ordinary products
to make them more delightful,
to make them do the right thing,
to make them behave in a
predictable and understandable
way.
Clocky is a clock
that has behavior,
and as Gauri likes
to say, it has
the behavior of a somewhat
troublesome pet that you still
love.
And in this case, we also
think the behavior is useful.
And one of the reasons
I believe that we've
seen such a response from press,
and just from ordinary people
to Clocky, is that they
understand exactly what it
does, and they think
that's going to help
them wake up in the morning.
- The concept for
Clocky originally
was not to use the most
advanced technology,
but to create a new place for
technology that was playful
and that has a personal meaning
for an individual's life.
Clocky is made up of a
small computer inside that
is programmed with a random
generating sequence of numbers
that control the speed
and the direction
that Clocky will move in.
And it's connected
to a couple of motors
and a couple of wheels,
and that does enable
it to move around the room.
When you hit the
snooze button, Clocky
will roll off the
bedside table and wheel
away on the floor running in
random directions and speeds,
until he finds a place to rest.
And every day, Clocky will
find a new place to rest,
so it's sort of like
a hide and seek game
that you play every morning.
Clocky is of course a research
project at the Media Lab,
and I'm currently developing
on more prototypes.
But Clocky could be soon be
in production within a year.
The Media Lab is a
great environment
for a project like
this to emerge.
I've been able to do
everything from fabricating
to programming, to
coming up with ideas
and thinking about real
world problems, all
in the space of one lab.
- Well, I think Clocky
answers a need that
is felt across cultures
throughout the world,
and that is being able
to get up in the morning
when one really doesn't want to.
And the snooze bar
makes it very easy
not to get up in the morning.
Well, in this case, Clocky lets
you use the snooze bar once,
and then you have to go find
the alarm clock in order
to turn it off the second time.
And by that point,
you're out of bed.
And it's a very simple
scenario to explain.
Anybody who has an alarm clock
can understand exactly why
this is an interesting idea.
And the kinds of responses
we've seen from people who
have written to us or
who have written on blogs
on the internet around
the world is that they
understand what this is about.
They may agree or
they may disagree,
but they can immediately
see what the point is.
[END PLAYBACK]
JONES: Okay, we're back.
More families, this is my
favorite part of the show.
So would you introduce yourself?
MOTHER 1: My name is
[INAUDIBLE] I actually
come from Los Angeles.
JONES: And who are you here for?
MOTHER 1: It's my son.
His name is Michael [? Tan. ?]
JONES: He's graduating with
a Bachelor's degree in--
MOTHER 1: EECS.
JONES: That's electrical
engineering and computer
science.
And you two.
MOTHER 2: Yes.
We are [INAUDIBLE]
[? Sugai ?] and today
my son Bruno is graduating
from comparative media studies.
JONES: He's getting
his Bachelor's degree?
MOTHER 2: Yes, he is.
JONES: We got a twofer here.
STUDENT 15: I'm Andre Sugai
I'm his little brother,
and also a CMS undergrad.
I'm a rising senior right now.
JONES: So two boys at MIT.
Yeah, you're pretty broke.
So tell me about your son.
MOTHER 1: He's pretty excited,
this is a dream school for him,
so he's very excited here.
Learn everything a lot here, so.
JONES: What high school
did he go to in LA?
MOTHER 1: He was at
Beverly High School.
JONES: Where?
MOTHER 1: Beverly
Hills High School.
JONES: So you're the one
responsible for the California
weather?
MOTHER 1: Yes, it's
wonderful here.
And also, we're here
for a day or two.
JONES: Because, you know,
those of you who are not
from New England,
you don't understand
that the month of May was
raining and freezing cold.
So we knew all the
Californians are here today.
Okay, so now your brother,
he's comparative media studies.
That's kind of a new
major here, right?
STUDENT 15: Yeah it's actually
the second graduating class
since it has become a major.
JONES: So it's safe to say
that you guys are pioneers?
STUDENT 15: I like to
think of it that way.
JONES: And now,
where are you from?
STUDENT 15: Well, we're from
South Carolina originally,
but my parents have recently
moved to Belmont, Mass.
JONES: Oh, Belmont.
Got to be close to the family.
MOTHER 2: Exactly.
JONES: I see.
MOTHER 2: Our two boys being
here, it was closer to home
than--
JONES: Do you have more at home?
MOTHER 2: No.
It's just Bruno and Andre.
JONES: And they're both at MIT.
So you're really a MIT family.
MOTHER 2: We are.
All our heart is with MIT.
JONES: So now what are you
going to do, do you think,
when you finish?
What's Bruno going to do, and
then what are you going to do?
STUDENT 15: Bruno is looking
into electronic music,
or digital music.
I'm more of an advertising
kind of person.
So that's probably
what I'm going to do.
JONES: So you're going to
be doing interesting summer
work, summer jobs?
STUDENT 15: Myself, I'm
working at the Tampa
Tribune for the summer, doing
the news media desk over there.
JONES: Tampa, Florida?
STUDENT 15: Yes.
And Bruno is currently
building his portfolio
and looking for some good
electronic music prospects
and he's also working with his
band, the Hong Kong Regulars.
So if you are around
here, go check them out.
JONES: Okay, so it's nice to
meet you, and congratulations.
And here you go, Tom.
ROSKO: Now we're going to take
another look at a research
video about a recent invention.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- This is Toddler.
And this is Dr. Russ Tedrake.
Together, they're covering
new ground at MIT.
- So we call the robot Toddler
because it learns to walk,
and because it
toddles when it walks.
- Toddler's a passive
dynamic walker.
That means he's a simple
mechanical device with joints.
In the past, the only way
these robots could walk
was to trundle down a slope.
They couldn't walk
on flat surfaces.
This is where Toddler steps
to the front of the class.
He's simple, like the
passive dynamic robots,
and he could walk on
flat surfaces, too.
The difference is, he uses
very little power to do so.
- We're letting the
dynamics of the robot
solve most of the
control problem,
and we just add a
little bit of energy
here or there to kind of
push and pull the robot.
And that's a much more
energy efficient strategy
for designing a walking robot.
It turned out that the dynamic
walking was a great way
to make a system
that could learn
in real time on a real machine.
- The robot has a computer
and battery packs on board,
and the steering is controlled
with a wireless connection
and a laptop, but Toddler
does a lot of the work itself.
Because the robot already
knew how to walk down a slope,
it required less work
to find a solution
for walking on the flat.
Dr. Tedrake gave
Toddler the ability
to use sensors that
communicate with motors.
So with each step
the robot takes,
it's able to make adjustments.
- And that's what
we call learning.
It's a simple idea,
but it's the best way
we can embody what we think the
nervous system is doing, too,
when we're talking
about learning.
When we put it on the flat, and
we start asking it to learn,
then it can actually change
the parameters quickly enough
that in we say, 20
minutes, to be safe--
in 20 minutes, it learns
to walk on the flat,
and it continues to adapt
to the terrain as it goes.
- Toddler can also be adjusted
to learn very quickly,
but with faster
learning comes a price.
- There's this very
interesting result
in learning theory, which tells
that you can't have learning
without generalization.
The problem is, when
you start generalizing,
then there's a possibility
that you'll overwrite things
that you've learned in the past.
- So if it learns
faster, the robot
will walk from
linoleum to carpet
with only a quick adjustment.
However, the return to linoleum
may take a little longer.
But it's easy to see that
Toddler has in fact learned,
and that ability has enabled
Toddler to tackle new terrain.
- It's just such a thrill
whenever you see the robot
walking, and especially when
you do it in a public place
and you can see all the
people go, oh, look,
it's a cool little robot.
- So how does
studying a robot that
walks like a human
actually benefit humans?
- So by just looking
at how a machine walks
and understanding that, we
can actually learn a lot
about how humans walk.
Ultimately, down the line--
far down the line-- if we
understand the motor learning
system better, then there's a
potential that we can use that
information to design
rehabilitation programs--
even neural
prosthetics-- to help
people recover from injuries
or augment their performance.
There's a lot of different
potential applications.
- As for Toddler, he's got a big
brother already in the works.
This new version
includes changes
such as smaller
feet, new components,
and a fine set of knees.
Knees that can both walk
and swing through a step
will enable the robot
to be more versatile.
It's also one of the
steps being taken to make
the robot appear more human--
something Dr. Tedrake thinks is
very important for the future
of robot design.
- When you see a robot
that looks like a human,
you kind of have a tendency
to reach out to it,
and it really helps, I
think, with the human-robot
interaction.
- Dr. Tedrake says
there is still
much to learn from
the original Toddler,
and from its new brother.
- It's an iterative process
where we basically start
adding components back
in and see just how
far the learning can take us.
And once you've built one,
and once you watched it walk,
the idea really sells itself.
I think it's the first step
in a long road of building
better robots, more
efficient robots,
and learning systems for robots.
[END PLAYBACK]
JONES: So let's see
what's happening over
in Johnson with our graduates.
They look like
they're all in line.
It looks like they're
in alpha order.
If they step out of line,
they don't graduate.
How many MIT students
can follow directions?
Good, a quick commercial break--
for those of you who want the
CD or video of this graduation,
you can order them
at the information
tables on either side in
the back of the court.
Every graduate will be
photographed as they graduate,
and you may want to purchase
one of those photos as well.
And you can arrange that at
those tables in the back.
So here, we're back with family.
Here's a wonderful
family from Canada.
So would you introduce yourself?
GILBERT: Hi, I'm Marcy Gilbert.
SCHACTER: And I'm
Shalom Schacter.
JONES: And who is your graduate?
GILBERT: Matye Gilbert-Schacter.
JONES: So his name is Matye?
SCHACTER: Correct.
JONES: And you're from where?
SCHACTER: We're from
Toronto, Canada.
JONES: In Toronto.
So you just reminded me that
this weather is not necessarily
California, it's
actually Toronto weather.
So we thank the Canadians.
The Canadians-- you know
what, a Canadian was a first
international student at MIT--
1866.
SCHACTER: The year before
Canada was confederated.
JONES: So a true pioneer.
So tell me a little about Matye.
SCHACTER: Well, Matye has been
only here for three years,
and he's had to take it all in.
He was a transfer student
from University of Toronto.
He switched disciplines
from engineering to physics,
and he'll be graduating with
a physics major and a minor
in mathematics.
JONES: In three years.
SCHACTER: Yes.
He's really enjoyed his stay.
He's dreamed as a
child of coming to MIT.
We tried to support
him and his dream,
but he made it come
true, and we're
very happy to be here to
see it come to fruition.
JONES: That's wonderful.
You know, we hear
about stories like this
where students have been
dreaming their whole life
to come.
And mostly we hear
those stories of people
of students we turn down.
So it's always wonderful
to hear that we actually
took people who've been dreaming
their whole lives about MIT.
It's wonderful.
So tell me a little
about Matye as a person.
GILBERT: Matye's a
wonderful person.
And he's going to be moving
on to Philadelphia, where
he'll be a trader with
one of the companies.
JONES: So he has sibs
at home in Toronto?
GILBERT: Yes.
He has one sibling who is
living in Waterloo right now,
attending the University
of Waterloo in engineering.
JONES: In engineering So
does this run in the family,
does it, this engineering thing?
SCHACTER: No.
My father in fact is a practical
person in terms of technology.
But we're both
social scientists,
although I did start myself
in the physics and mathematics
as an undergraduate.
JONES: So was Matye
on the screen before?
SCHACTER: Yes, he was.
JONES: Oh, he was.
I thought I remembered his name.
So he was with the
first group of students.
SCHACTER: That's right.
He's been active in many of
the special resources at MIT.
He's been active in sports.
He took pistols, which
was a shock to us.
He was active in the
student organizations--
he became president of
Hillel, the Jewish student
organization.
And he was active
in his fraternity.
JONES: I remember Matye now.
Oh yeah.
GILBERT: It's nice to
know that he's remembered.
JONES: Oh yes.
Every student at MIT is
handpicked, you know.
It's true.
And we don't take very many
transfer students each day,
so this is good.
So where does he live here?
SCHACTER: Well, he's moved into
the fraternity house that's
on the other side of
the Charles River,
but for the first
year that he was here,
he was in a number
of the residences.
JONES: So I'm so happy he's
had a good experience here,
and it's a pleasure to meet you.
And now we're going to
turn it back to Tom.
GILBERT: Thank you.
ROSKO: Now, MIT
is very well known
for its first-class engineering
education and research.
But MIT also has an
excellent arts program,
and it compliments all
the other disciplines.
In fact, the arts
and humanities have
been a part of MIT's
educational experience
since MIT's very founding.
And when William Barton
Rogers, MIT's founder
and first President,
drew up the plan
of what the education
at MIT should be,
the humanities and arts were
a key part of the curriculum.
And over the years,
that part that
includes humanities and
the arts and its importance
has always been a part of MIT's
curriculum and its education.
And in fact, MIT prides itself
on educating lifelong learners
who understand the societal
and humanistic effects
of technology and science.
And now we offer you
an excerpt of a program
overview of the arts at MIT.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- One morning, I came up the
steps of Massachusetts Avenue,
and walked through the door.
And the entire space had been
transformed into a wheat field.
Innovative visual arts projects
like that are happening
all the time on campus.
The arts at MIT, like science
and engineering at MIT,
are on the cutting edge
of their disciplines.
They are serving the students.
And in the way they're
serving the students,
ultimately they're going to
be serving the entire society.
- At MIT, you'll find some of
the best musicians-- virtuosos,
completely.
A person who lives next door
to me has perfect pitch,
and if you name any
song whatsoever he
can strum it out on his guitar.
If it has multiple
lines of music,
he can strum out all
lines on his guitar.
And you can see that it's
indicative of the level
of quality of the MIT symphony
orchestra, the MIT concert
choir, et cetera.
- Last year I got to
premier a song cycle
written by an MIT composer,
and that was a lot of fun.
Modern poetry, modern
music, and everything.
- Everyone at MIT
cares about something,
whether it's their
classes or their UROP,
or some student
activity they do.
There's always something
that they really care about.
- The thing about MIT students
that I most appreciate
is the elegance
of their thinking,
and the fact that it's sort
of "live and let live" here.
[GROUP SINGING]
There's a point of concentration
that any discipline requires,
whether it's engineering
or it's directing
for acting, or painting.
That point of concentration
is the focal point.
It is the thing around which
you organize your thinking
and your technique.
And so the fact that there is
ensemble work, where people
learn to work
collaboratively, is something
that I see that people take
into their labs in a way
that you would hope that
labs work collaboratively.
[MUSIC - ROB THOMAS, "SMOOTH"]
- (SINGING) Cuz
you're so smooth.
And it's just like the
ocean under the moon,
it's the same as the
emotion that I get from you.
You got the kind of loving
that can be so smooth, yeah.
Give me your heart, make it
real, or else forget about it.
[LAUGHTER]
- I'll kill you!
- Ooh!
He kills me.
Ooh!
- Well, right now,
it's sort of--
theater is a way
I can investigate
my own sort of
identity, especially
my own cultural identity.
But I also enjoy theater because
it's such a collaborative art,
and it's a lot like engineering,
which is one of my majors.
And I also intend to
pursue engineering,
and that is so collaborative.
And so you get a lot of
different people's perspective
on things.
- We find our students--
a certain number of them go
on to graduate study in music
and in the arts.
Some of them go on to become
leaders of arts organizations
within their communities.
Some of them go on to sing in
organizations or performing
organizations, like the
Tanglewood Festival Chorus.
And in a couple of notable
situations, I have myself
a number of times have been
engaged by organizations
whose presidents were either in
my class at MIT 20 years ago,
or had been at MIT
years before that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
My first visit to MIT, when
I walked through the halls,
I remember passing through
the math department
on the way to Building
14, where we used to be.
And I looked in the door and
saw mathematicians hunched
in carols, and I
felt right at home,
because that looked
exactly like walking down
the halls of Juilliard
into the practice rooms,
and seeing people working
personally on something.
- One of the amazing
things about MIT students
is the incredible wide range
of interests and abilities
that extend far beyond the
intellectual and the academic.
And our special guest with us,
this section of the concert
is no exception to that.
His name is Jonathan Lee.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- I think that being involved
in activities like this
only enhances your education.
I think it's important
that while you're
at school to focus on things
besides your own research.
- So people come here as
scientists, as engineers,
as mathematicians.
But when they are making
art, they're artists.
- I think that it's
a way of chilling out
some of the stresses you have.
It's a way of looking
at the things you're
doing with a broader picture.
[GROUP SINGING "WE ARE THE
ENGINEERS"]
- So you shouldn't
think that MIT
has no art, because they've
got them like sprawling
all over the place.
- Well, now, the advice I
give to incoming freshmen
consistently is don't
leave your trumpet at home.
You can use it here.
- (SINGING) Engineers!
- Go, go, go, go, go, go--
- Engineers!
- We are, we are, we
are the engineers.
- Engineers!
- We are, we are, we
are the engineers.
- Engineers!
- We are, we are, we
are the engineers.
- Engineers!
- We are, we are, we
are the engineers.
- A lady and an engineer
were sitting in the park,
and the engineer was working
on some research after dark.
His scientific method
was a wonder to observe.
While his right hand--
[END PLAYBACK]
JONES: Okay.
We got progress.
I understand the procession
may have already begun.
Let's take a look at what's
happening in Johnson.
Here they come.
Just so you know,
they're across Mass Ave.
in the Johnson Athletic Center.
They're going to
come across, they're
going to come down
Mass Ave., they're
going to curve
around Memorial Drive
down here to the
bottom of the court.
And very shortly, the
commencement will begin,
and they will enter straight
up the middle aisle.
So this is-- we've
already begun.
So we have one more
interview for a family,
because then you have to
quickly grab your seats
and get ready for this big show.
So why don't you
introduce yourselves here,
and who are you here for?
FATHER 1: My name is
Melvin [? Magny. ?]
My son is Eric Magny, and he's
graduating from biology today.
STUDENT 16: I'm his
sister, Sonya Magny.
MOTHER 3: I am [INAUDIBLE]
Magny, Eric's mother.
STUDENT 17: And I'm Melvin
Magny, Eric's brother.
JONES: And Melvin, you
are a junior here, right?
Good, so another brother at MIT.
So tell me about Eric.
So what's his degree
going to be in?
STUDENT 16: Biology.
JONES: It's good
to be in biology.
And then what is
Eric going to do?
STUDENT 16: He's going
to UCLA for med school.
JONES: He's going
to be a doctor.
STUDENT 16: Yep.
JONES: That's good.
This is how he's going to
take care of you parents, huh?
So you which department
are you in, Melvin?
STUDENT 17: I'm in biology, too.
JONES: And you're
in biology as well.
Same kind of track.
STUDENT 17: Basically, yep.
JONES: Are you guys doctors?
FATHER 1: Yes.
MOTHER 3: Yes.
JONES: Oh, you're an
all doctor family.
So if you have an
emergency here,
we know who to call right now.
And how about you?
So you're a junior
in high school?
STUDENT 16: Yes, in Florida.
JONES: Where?
STUDENT 16: Florida.
JONES: In Florida?
STUDENT 16: Mhm.
JONES: And then what
are you going to do?
STUDENT 16: Hopefully
come to MIT, I don't know.
JONES: Well, you're talking
to the right person.
So where is your family from?
MOTHER 3: Florida.
STUDENT 16: Florida.
MOTHER 3: We are from
Fort Pierce, Florida.
JONES: Where's Fort Pierce?
MOTHER 3: It's in--
STUDENT 16: Hurricane.
MOTHER 3: It's 100
miles north of--
FATHER 1: Miami.
North of Miami.
MOTHER 3: It could
be Miami or Orlando.
JONES: So how many hurricanes
did you get hit by last year?
STUDENT 16: Two in a row.
JONES: Two in a row.
Everything's okay
with your home?
MOTHER 3: No, no.
JONES: Bad story.
So tell me about
Eric and Melvin.
STUDENT 17: Eric's a great
guy, and he'll be here soon.
And I mean, he has
really given himself
to MIT these four
years, and he's
one of the reasons I'm here.
And he also took a lot
from it, so he's also
someone to learn from.
JONES: And so you said he would
perform at any place, any time.
STUDENT 17: Yeah.
I mean, he was big
in the culture shows,
he emceed two culture shows,
he was varsity tennis all four
years, he did research.
He was an active member of
our house, the vise president
of our house, PB.
And just all around,
he was all over MIT.
JONES: So he sounds like a very
active and fun student, huh?
So how about you?
Are you the same way?
STUDENT 17: I'm kind
of the same way.
JONES: You're kind
of the same way?
Are you a performer too?
STUDENT 17: Yeah, I
do some performing.
I do some class council
work, same varsity tennis
and research, and basically
pre-med track, so.
JONES: So next year,
you're going to be here--
is it next year or
the year after they're
going to be here for you?
STUDENT 17: Two years.
JONES: Two more years.
Okay.
Well, it's a
pleasure to meet you,
and you better get your
seats, because they're coming,
and they're going to be coming
around the corner any second.
Thanks very much.
MOTHER 3: Pleasure meeting you.
JONES: Oh, you're welcome.
And now, I'm going to turn you
over to Tom Rosko, my buddy.
You'll notice he's at the top
of the Court at this stage.
Wave to Tom.
Hi, Tom!
Tom has some--
ROSKO: Hi everybody.
JONES: --announcements for
everyone, so listen up.
ROSKO: I have just a few
public service announcements.
We know that each of
you is very anxious
to get the best photograph or
the best look at your graduate,
but we just ask that
you be courteous and not
stand on the chairs
or block the aisles,
and just think about the
people that are trying to watch
as well from behind you.
And also, there's
a medical tent.
It's located at the
rear of Killian Court.
And the commencement
program contains the words
to the national
anthem and MIT's song.
And we also request that if you
have cell phones, if you put
them in a non-audible position.
And now, I'd like to
say that the MIT color
guard is about to
come up representing
the MIT police and the ROTC--
I believe-- with the
presentation of the colors.
And then-- sorry,
just the MIT police.
And after that,
we'll hand you over
to Larry Isaacson and
the MIT Brass Ensemble.
So once again, I was Tom Rosko--
I am Tom Rosko, the
Institute Archivist here,
and my partner was Marilee
Jones, Dean of Admissions.
And we hope you enjoyed what
we did for you this morning,
and also that-- thank you--
and also that the
procession has begun.
Congratulations to
the graduates of 2005,
and we hope you
enjoy the ceremony.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC - BACH, "SHEEP MAY SAFELY
GRAZE"]
[NO AUDIO]
[MUSIC - HARDIMAN, "LORD OF THE
DANCE"]
[NO AUDIO]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JONES: Yes, we're ready.
Can you hear us, Larry?
Okay.
[FANFARE MUSIC PLAYING]
ROSKO: Welcome to MIT's
139th commencement exercise
the commencement of
the class of 2005
I'm Tom Rosko, the
Institute Archivist and head
of MIT's archives and
special collections.
JONES: And I'm Marilee Jones,
the Dean of Admissions at MIT.
We will provide
commentary leading up
to the beginning of the
commencement ceremony,
and offer insight into
what you're witnessing,
as well as providing some
current and historical context.
ROSKO: Periodically,
we'll break away
to allow our listeners
to appreciate
the ambience of the
courtyard, and to listen
to the processional music
being played in Killian Court
by the MIT Brass Ensemble.
We welcome those
just joining us,
and we welcome our audience
from across the MIT
campus, the greater
Boston campus community,
and from around the world.
And thanks to MIT professor
emeritus Jay Keyser,
and retired MIT museum
director Warren Seamans,
for their work on the
previous MIT's commencement.
Thank you, Jay, and
thank you, Warren.
Now, here we are at MIT.
MIT was founded in 1865,
and its first commencement
was held in 1868.
And what you're
seeing now is a view
of the great Court, the
main Great Dome of MIT,
which was built and
completed in 1916.
MIT's original campus
was across the Charles
River in Boston's Back Bay, and
it was known as Boston Tech.
So its first classes
were held in 1865,
and then the move
occurred in 1916.
And the first commencement
exercises held in Killian--
in the Court area were
in 1917 in celebration.
And then in 1922,
when a tent blew down,
they moved the exercises inside.
But back in 1979,
they once again
moved to this the greater
Court that you see here,
and commencement has
been held outside
ever since-- except in 1992,
when severe weather forced it
inside.
JONES: I've always been struck
by how the Dome in Lobby 10
looks like the Pantheon in Rome.
ROSKO: Indeed, it does.
The architecture is actually
the Beaux-arts style,
drawing from Roman
and Greek influences.
And it's an interesting set of
buildings in that it's really
one giant building with
interconnected smaller
buildings with
corridors, so that--
and it was designed
purposely that way,
so that the students
and the faculty
could share ideas and be
able to work together more
easily than having to run
from one building to another.
JONES: I think of those
corridors coming off the Lobby
10 area and into the court as
being great arms reaching out,
surrounding the students.
ROSKO: Now what we'll be
seeing today for commencement
is a procession, and the
honor guard of MIT police
has already walked
with the colors
and presented them at
the-- on the podium.
And then there'll be
an academic procession
led by the president of
the Association of Alumni
and Alumnae, Linda Sharpe.
And then she'll be followed
by the stage principals,
including MIT's President,
Susan Hockfield, as well
as past presidents; the
Corporation chair; the mayor
of Cambridge, Michael
Sullivan; the individual giving
the invocation--
Swami Tyagananda; the provost;
the chancellor; and the deans.
They'll be followed by
members of the Corporation,
and then members of the faculty,
members of the Class of 1955.
Each 50th-year reunion class
marches in commencement.
And then following that
will be the guests of honor,
the graduates.
The ceremony itself will include
a greeting from the Chair
of the Corporation; the
national anthem, sung by the MIT
Chorallaries; the invocation
by the Hindu chaplain;
guest speaker, who this year
is Irwin Jacobs, the former CEO
of Qualcomm; and then a
salute to the class given
by the president of the graduate
student council, Barun Singh.
Then the class gift,
given by the President
of the Class of 2005,
Rohit Gupta; and then the
charge to the class given
by President Hockfield.
And following that will be the
actual awarding of degrees.
And that will occur on both
sides of the stage, the left
and the right side, and
each graduate will actually
get their individual degree.
And then after that
is the Association
of Alumni and Alumnae President
Linda Sharpe will speak.
Then we'll have the school
song and then the recession.
JONES: Oh, there's Tom Byrne,
the husband of Susan Hockfield,
president of MIT.
ROSKO: Dr. Tom
Byrne, who actually
has an appointment with I
believe Brain and Cognitive
Sciences faculty here,
and also at Manhasset--
Massachusetts General Hospital.
Once again, we see a
shot of the Great Dome,
and what you see
there is the stage,
and the empty seats will
be filled up momentarily
by the graduates who
are currently processing
from the Johnson
Athletic Center, which
is on the west side of campus.
This would be the
central part of campus.
The procession began a few
moments ago, and at any moment
now, we'll see the president
of the Association of Alumni
and Alumnae coming
forth, carrying the mace.
And following her will be
the academic procession.
JONES: It's an
absolute beautiful day
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
PA ANNOUNCER: Ladies
and gentlemen,
the academic procession,
led by the Chief Marshal,
will now enter Killian Court.
[FANFARE MUSIC PLAYING]
ROSKO: And there we see the
President of the Association
of Alumni and
Alumnae, Linda Sharpe,
followed by on her right--
the camera's left--
Susan Hockfield, and
on the other side
is Dana Mead, the Chair
of the Corporation.
Behind them are the former
chairs of the Corporation,
as well as past
presidents at MIT.
The mace she's carrying--
the gold stick--
is a gift from
the class of 1907,
given at the time of
their 50th class reunion.
It's created by [? Leverett ?]
Kutten of the Class of 1907,
and it's adorned with a--
on top of it is a beaver--
which is the MIT mascot--
nature's engineer.
And there are also some symbols
of acorns and oak leaves,
which symbolize strength.
And then around are other
symbols representing various--
representing symbols
that are representative
of the technological
culture of MIT,
rather than specific
courses of study.
The procession is making
its way up to the Great Dome
from the Charles River
basin along Memorial Drive
at the foot of the campus.
Now, President Hockfield was
just inaugurated this past--
about a month ago.
She became the 16th president
and took office December 6
of 2004.
She was MIT's first
woman president, and also
the first life scientist.
The robe she's wearing-- you see
the colors of the silver gray
and the cardinal red--
are the colors of
MIT, which were
established in 1875 by a vote
of the faculty and the alumni.
We see the various
deans coming through.
JONES: We love these
beautiful robes
from all the different schools.
ROSKO: The academic
garb, the caps and gowns,
date back to the 12th
and 13th centuries,
and it actually stems
from the clerical garb,
because many of the original
institutions of learning
were based in
religious societies.
And the colors
represent the various--
often the robes will be
of the school attended,
and then the hoods
representing the school
and the doctoral degrees.
JONES: There's Michael Sullivan,
the mayor of Cambridge.
ROSKO: We see in the back
Rafael [? Bras ?] carrying
the shepherd's staff, and
he is the current chair
of the faculty.
JONES: There's Howard Johnson--
ROSKO: Former MIT president
in the late 1960s,
and also former chair
of the Corporation.
There you see all of the
diplomas to be handed out,
which is something
MIT didn't always do.
it was actually in 19--
and most universities
don't do that today.
It's actually something
special about MIT.
Originally, before
1923 they used
to simply put all the
diplomas in a big basket,
and have the
graduates just run up
and get which ones they
wanted to try and find theirs.
Here, we see the
procession of MIT faculty.
JONES: Better not mix
up those diplomas.
ROSKO: Here we see
some of the marshals.
Each of the different academic
divisions that are processing
are led by a marshal and
also associate marshals.
Those would be those in the
more floppier cardinal red caps.
JONES: That is Kim Vandiver,
Professor and Associate Dean
for Undergraduate Education.
ROSKO: And head of
the Edgerton Center.
JONES: An all-around
wonderful guy.
ROSKO: You see the faculty
precessing in two lines.
One side of the
stage will be awarded
the undergraduate degrees
for the most part,
and then the other side will
be the graduate degrees.
And there once again, we
see MIT's mace, the symbol
of the academic procession.
The music you hear
in the background
is the MIT Brass Ensemble, being
conducted by Larry Isaacson.
And here we see precessing
members of the Class of 1955.
It's become a commencement
part that the 50th reunion
class does process,
and you see that they
have their class jackets,
which are awarded
to members of the 50th class.
JONES: In those days, their
favorite activities coming out
of high school were music,
ham radio, and tinkering.
ROSKO: And how has that
changed with the classes
today, Marilee?
JONES: Well, the
most recent class,
their favorite activities
were volunteering,
music and the arts, leadership
activities, and athletics.
Very different
life for kids today
than for the 17-year-olds
of the Class of 1955.
ROSKO: In the class
of 2005, there
are 2177 undergraduate
and graduate students.
There will be awarded 1,094
Bachelor's degrees, 1078
Master's degrees, 257 Doctorates
and 12 engineering degrees.
And here, we see a shot of
President Hockfield talking
to the provost, Bob Brown.
And behind her,
left to right, we
see Alice Gast, the
Associate Dean of Research;
and Claude Canizares,
Associate Provost--
Alice Gast is
behind, I believe, members
of the Corporation.
And I believe that
was Irwin Jacobs
we saw standing next to Susan.
He will be today's
guest speaker.
JONES: Isn't it wonderful to
see all those red jackets.
ROSKO: The alumni
certainly have a warmth
for MIT and their
experiences here,
as you can tell by the number.
JONES: Many of these people are
the reasons why this nation is
so prosperous today.
ROSKO: Here we see a shot of
the stage, and on the podium
we see a view of MIT's seal,
which if we get a shot later,
we'll probably talk a
little more about that.
JONES: More than a
decade ago, there
was a study by
the Bank of Boston
of all of the employment
provided by graduates of MIT
over time.
It determined that
our alumni together
created the 24th largest
GNP in the world.
Mind and hands indeed.
ROSKO: And here we see the
marshal for the faculty, Paul
Lagace, standing next to
Linda Sharpe of the Alumni
Association.
JONES: Paul's professor in
Aeronautics and Astronautics.
ROSKO: And a big
Boston Red Sox fan.
JONES: And a great
baseball player.
PA ANNOUNCER: --the guests
of honor, the Class of 2005.
[APPLAUSE]
JONES: And now, the
real guests of honor
are graduates themselves.
[BRASS MUSIC PLAYING]
ROSKO: They are being led
by the Dean of Students,
Larry Benedict, on the left.
JONES: And my boss.
ROSKO: At the
right, Bob Redwine--
JONES: The dean of
undergraduate education.
They look pretty spiffy
with those hats on.
ROSKO: You note some
of the students dressed
in different regalia.
Some of the recipients
of doctoral degrees
are wearing the MIT colors,
with the robes-- with the three
bars on the sleeves denoting
the doctoral degree.
JONES: They're moving
nice and slowly so
that people don't
get out of line.
It almost looks like one of
those slow-motion movies.
It's really quite
a beautiful sight.
ROSKO: And it is quite
a scene here today
with not only the lovely
weather, but also--
it's packed to the brim with
students and well-wishers,
the family of the graduates.
JONES: The energy at MIT
is very different today.
Commencement is
always such a joy.
The energy is relief,
relaxation, fun, it's real joy
here.
Very different from the
rest of the year, where
people are buckling down
and getting their work done.
It's very similar to
the first day of school,
but much more relaxed.
Very happy day.
ROSKO: And as well
as the marshals--
we see Larry Benedict
and Bob Redwine--
behind them are the
associate marshals--
Professor Deb Fitzgerald and
Professor Leslie Norford,
as well as Rohit Gupta, the
President of the Class of 2005.
And Mr. John [? Blasko, ?]
the Treasurer of the class,
and Barun Singh, the President
of the Graduate Student
Council.
And Hector Hernandez,
the Vice President
of the Graduate Student Council,
followed by Julie Norman,
the head assistant marshal.
JONES: You can see they're
coming in four lines.
Two will go to the left, and
two will go to the right.
I have to say, as
Dean of Admissions,
my heart really
bursts with pride
when I see these young people,
because in the Admissions
Office, we have handpicked every
single one of those students.
It is very difficult
to be admitted here.
ROSKO: Marilee,
perhaps you could
talk a little bit about the
admission process itself,
then-- what the students
did to get into MIT.
JONES: Well, they had to
be extraordinarily prepared
in terms of their academic
work, but they also
had to be a good match for MIT.
They had to be
very self-motivated
and have some kind of
emotional resilience,
not being afraid of failure.
They have-- we look for people
who are willing to risk,
because at MIT students
risk themselves every day.
There's a great look.
They risk their egos every day.
They need to be brave.
And there are so many thousands
of students who apply here,
nearly 11,000 this year for this
soon-to-enter freshman class.
For this particular
group, the Class of 2005,
we had about 10,500
of them applying.
and we admitted just
18% of those students.
They're really extraordinary.
For those of you listening
who are MIT graduates,
you may wonder if you had been
admitted today, many of us
look at these
students and think,
"We would never get
admitted to college today,
and we feel very
badly about it."
And I just want
to let you know--
you should not feel
bad, because we admit
the best of each generation.
And you alumni out there
were the best of yours.
ROSKO: Very nicely said.
JONES: It's comparing
the apples and oranges,
but now I'm going to really
shock you by telling you that
the average-- the mean SAT
scores for this particular
class as you're watching
them enter was 711 Verbal--
that's 711 out of 800, folks--
and 756 Math.
So many of you alumni
from previous years
may not have scores like that.
You might have had
high Math scores,
but perhaps the verbal wasn't
where you wanted it to be.
These young ones
are extraordinary.
41% of them were valedictorians
of their high school classes.
Well over 90% of them are in the
top 5% of their high schools.
They were very well
prepared coming in.
And every single one of those
students out there has a story.
They come from
somewhere, they come
from a family who loves them.
Every one of them have had
to face tough times at MIT.
They've been
challenged to the max.
As you know, this is a
very rigorous curriculum,
and they all made it.
They come from 56
different countries
in the world, this group.
48 different languages
spoken in their homes.
That and a 711 mean
SAT Verbal score.
Am I proud of my kids?
Yes, I am.
ROSKO: And well you
should be, Marilee.
JONES: Anybody
who knows me knows
I take full responsibility
for everyone in the class.
When they do
something wonderful,
I write them little
notes of pride.
When they do something
that's not so wonderful,
I blame everybody else.
[LAUGHTER]
ROSKO: Now, this year's
Class of 2005 also certainly
was different from
the Class of 1905.
The much earlier alumni and
graduates was a class of 244,
and as far as foreign countries
represented, they were three--
Brazil, England, and Ireland.
And there were only 18 master's
degrees awarded that year.
And 55% of the class--
or of the student body
came from Massachusetts.
The number of clubs that
they were involved in was 11.
The number of sports were 10,
including a tug of war team,
and the number of
musical clubs three.
Here, we see another side of
the stage and the principals
sitting there, members of--
the deans, the members of the
Corporation, the marshals,
various members of the
faculty seated at the front,
and department heads and chairs.
Also I said members of the
Corporation towards the back.
Once again, you note
the different regalia
that's being worn.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JONES: The students have
been told to just follow
the student in front of them--
no matter what follow the
student in front of them.
So now we get to see how
well they take direction.
ROSKO: And it really is quite
a process to award each student
their degrees.
I say it will be
done in two parts.
It will be simultaneously
the degrees being given.
At the left side of the
stage, President Hockfield
will present the Bachelor
of Science degrees,
the Bachelor of Science slash
Master of Science degrees,
Bachelor of Science slash
Master of Engineering--
that would be on the left
side of the stage looking out.
Also President Hockfield--
I know you see a shot
of President Hockfield talking
to the guest speaker Irwin
Jacobs--
President Hockfield
will also give out
advanced degrees in
the School of Science,
the Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institution,
and the Whitaker College of
Health Sciences and Technology.
The right side,
provost Bob Brown
will award advanced degrees
in the School of Architecture
and Planning, the
School of Engineering,
the School of Humanities,
Arts and Social Sciences,
and the Sloan School
of Management.
JONES: Glad to see that
Susan Hockfield is staying
hydrated up there on the stage.
It's very warm in the
Great Court today,
and everyone has a big bottle
of water under their chair.
Push fluids.
ROSKO: I'm sure no one minds
the heat after the rain and cold
that we've had for
the month of May.
JONES: What a May we had.
This is Susan's
first commencement.
She looks like she's
having a wonderful time.
There's Dana Mead, Chairman
of the Corporation,
and Howard Johnson.
ROSKO: Howard Johnson,
former president
of MIT in the late
1960s early 1970s,
and then also a former chair--
JONES: There's Paul Gray.
ROSKO: Paul Gray, the
president from 1980 to 1990.
JONES: I want to say just a
quick word about Paul Gray.
Paul Gray's a true
citizen of MIT.
He reminds me of
George Washington
in that after serving as
President and then Chairman
of the Corporation, he's
gone back onto the faculty.
And he's now joining
our admissions office
faculty oversight committee,
the Committee on Undergraduate
Admissions and
Financial Aid, which
is staffed by faculty members.
He has not served on CUAFA
for many years, and he's back.
ROSKO: And there
in the middle, we
saw a shot of the Mayor of
Cambridge, Michael Sullivan.
And he was talking to Alex
d'Arbeloff, former chair--
the preceding chair of
the MIT Corporation.
So some facts about MIT itself.
There are over 10,000 students--
approximately 4,000
undergraduate students,
and approximately 6,000
graduate students.
There are 900-- over
almost 1,000 faculty,
including 178 women, and
there are nearly 10,000 staff.
MIT consists of five schools.
There's the School
of Engineering,
the School of Science, the
School of Humanities and Social
Sciences, the School of
Architecture and Urban
Planning, and the Sloan
School of Management,
as well as the Whitaker
College of Health Sciences
and Technology.
You see some members
of the Corporation.
The MIT Corporation is
the governing body of MIT.
The president reports
to them, and we
see in the bottom-left
Kathryn Willmore,
who is the secretary
of the Corporation.
So the MIT Corporation would be
similar to a board of trustees,
or a board of regents.
[FANFARE MUSIC PLAYING]
Many of them are
members of the faculty--
I mean, members of the alumni.
In fact, just 100 years
ago, the Alumni Association
was strengthened through--
there was a proposed merger--
one of several in
the history of MIT--
with Harvard University.
And the alumni did
not want to see that.
However, the
Corporation and its vote
voted that the
merger should occur.
This was to have MIT become
sort of the School of Science
of Harvard--
I mean, the School
of Engineering
of Harvard University.
But it was a vote, and
many of the Corporation
were actually Harvard graduates.
But the Alumni
Association fought back
and petitioned against it.
It was actually a legal
case that MIT was not
allowed to join the merger
because their land, which
was at that time in Boston's
Back Bay, could not be sold.
But anyway, that really was a
strengthening of the alumni,
and in fact, more Corporation
members since that time
have been MIT alumni.
JONES: Well, was
that a good decision.
Because MIT is the
premier university
of science and
technology on the planet.
ROSKO: It is, and it was
founded to be a stand-alone
institution, and there were
other thoughts that it might--
it was really a new
sort of way of thinking
when MIT was founded, as to
what a polytechnic institute
should be, and would be.
And William Barton
Rogers, MIT's founder--
JONES: My hero.
ROSKO: --established
a scope and a plan
as to what that should
include, and it was not just
the applied sciences.
It was that there should
be a firm founding as well
in the humanities and the arts,
which continues to this day,
and has been reinforced many
times over the importance
of a well-rounded education,
but also an education that
does solve problems.
JONES: He added to the
charter after the Civil War
that MIT should teach students
to apply science and technology
for the benefit of humankind,
because he lost family members,
his wife lost a brother
in the Civil War.
He lived in Virginia, although
he was actually a Northerner,
and lost many friends in
that terrible tragedy.
And he could not believe
how so many good people
could do such stupid things.
ROSKO: And it continues
as MIT's mission
to have an impact on the
world and for the betterment
of mankind.
JONES: That's what they all do.
It's a pleasure to
look out over these--
so many students are about to
be unleashed into the world.
When you think of all the
previous people from MIT gone
into the world, and all the good
that they do because they fix
the world for the people who
can't fix it for themselves,
for the disenfranchised.
And I just look at
the sea of faces
and think of all
the potential there.
Just think of all the
magic that they're going
to bring into this planet.
I want to say one thing
about the Class of 2005--
they entered MIT
in September 2001.
So they had about two
weeks of the old world,
and then September
11th happened,
and their lives changed, as
all of our lives changed.
MIT had a lot of pressure,
as other universities did
after that, to close its doors
to international students,
to close its doors
to researchers,
and fought back very hard
to remain a free university.
The currency of universities,
the lifeblood of universities
is ideas.
And our previous president,
Chuck Vest, fought very hard.
ROSKO: And the sharing with
those ideas with the world
is something that MIT
has always promoted.
There we see in the
front Paul Lagace
again, one of the marshals.
And talking to Susan Hockfield
is today's guest speaker
Irwin Jacobs.
And--
JONES: Bob Brown, the provost.
Next to him, Phil
Clay, the chancellor.
Next to him--
ROSKO: Chair of the
faculty, Rafael Bras
in the wonderful regalia.
JONES: It's a great, puffy
neck thing he has on there.
ROSKO: In the back, we see
the Dean of Graduate Students,
Ike Colbert; the Dean of
Architecture and Urban
Planning, Adéle Santos;
and the Dean of the School
of Humanities, Arts, and
Social Sciences, Phil Khoury.
JONES: Dick Schmalensee
of the Sloan School,
the Dean of Sloan School.
ROSKO: And then Tom Magnanti
just exiting the screen
as the Dean of the
School of Engineering.
Today's guest
speaker, Irwin Jacobs,
is an MIT alumnus,
with a master's in--
Doctorate in Science.
He's a former faculty member
in electrical engineering,
and co-founder and chairman
and CEO of Qualcomm.
He's known as an innovative
entrepreneur and engineer who
places high value on research.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JONES: Ah, yes
there's Tom Magnanti--
ROSKO: --leaning
forward, sitting next
to Dick Schmalensee,
Dean of the Sloan School.
JONES: Tom's wearing
a nice outfit.
ROSKO: That's Princeton
colors, I believe.
JONES: I see.
I see Phil Khoury there.
ROSKO: He has Harvard colors.
JONES: Dean of the Humanities,
Arts, and Social Sciences
school.
ROSKO: Adéle Santos, the Dean
of the School of Architecture
and Urban Planning.
And once again to the bottom,
Phil Clay, the chancellor.
To the left up above,
we see Ike Colbert,
the Dean of Graduate Students.
JONES: Wonderful hat.
ROSKO: And Provost Bob Brown--
Bob Brown, being the
highest academic officer
of the Institute-- aside from
the president-- and the Deans
would report to him.
JONES: Chancellor Phil
Clay, and Rafael Bras.
ROSKO: The chancellor dealing
with student-related activities
and services, for the
most part, and Rafael Bras
is chair of the faculty,
representing them.
We see a lot of
colors coming through,
with MIT's colors
there-- the gray and--
the silver gray and
the cardinal red.
And now at MIT, only doctoral
degree recipients wear hoods,
and indeed there was a
hooding ceremony yesterday,
where they all
received as you see
there the hood behind that
graduate walking past.
JONES: They're so happy.
They're so glad to be
out of graduate school.
ROSKO: The doctoral
degrees, the PhD,
has a blue velvet trim,
and the doctor of science
a yellow velvet
trim, and the lining
would be the school colors.
Here, we see Bob Redwine, Dean
of Undergraduates to the left.
Linda Sharpe, the President
of the Association
of Alumni and Alumnae.
JONES: There's Dean
Larry Benedict, who's
the Dean for Student Life.
There's Gayle Gallagher.
You see Barun Singh, President
of the Grad Student Council,
and Hector Hernandez, who's
the Vice President of the Grad
Student.
ROSKO: We also got a shot
there of Gayle Gallagher, who
is the ranger of this event, and
coordinating all this activity
that must go on.
Every year.
JONES: Commencement star.
She rules.
She does a fabulous job.
There's Barun and Hector of
the Graduate Student Council.
[LAUGHS]
ROSKO: And you note
some military uniforms,
and MIT has an ROTC program,
representing the three
branches-- the Marines,
the Air Force, and--
I mean, the Army,
Marines, and Navy.
And actually, ROTC
and military training
has been a part of MIT's history
since the very beginning.
MIT was partially founded
as a land-grant university
by the Morrill Land-Grant
Act, and that was compulsory
as part of that training.
Of course, it was also
just during the Civil War
that MIT came about.
JONES: So here's Bob Redwine
in the middle, and then
we see Rohit Gupta, who is the
President of the Class of 2005,
and then you see
John [? Velazco, ?]
who's the Treasurer
of the Class of 2005.
We see Professor Deb Fitzgerald,
who is the associate marshal.
Look at all those
beautiful faces.
The class that entered in 1970--
the average number of
extracurriculars coming out
of high school was four.
And with this particular
class, the average number
of extracurriculars that
the students did was 12.
So it shows you how the
culture has changed.
Again, in 1970, the percentage
of students entering
with a well-defined interest
in music, the number one
activity at MIT, was 24%
entering the class of 1970.
This particular
graduating class was 60%.
So 60% of these kids that you
see out here in the Great Court
graduating entered MIT with
well-defined and distinguished
backgrounds in music,
and that tells you
how the culture has changed.
We see athletics
as well in 1970--
19% of the students came
in as varsity athletes,
versus 58% of the class
you see in front of you,
the class of 2005.
That's the effect of
Title IX from the 1970s
that brought gender equity
in athletics, and also
in many other areas
of life as well.
It really opened up athletics.
Activities in theater in
the class entering 1970--
4% came in with
theater background.
This particular
class-- over 28%.
Some very talented performers
in the class of 2005.
ROSKO: And the culture
of MIT is often not
what you think it would be.
It's amazing the value placed
on the arts, and just the talent
that there is.
As you walk down
the halls, what you
might stereotype as an MIT
student is nothing like they
are.
And there's-- walking
down the halls,
there's music playing
from various classrooms.
The various talents
that the students
have not just as
tinkerers, or being
able to fix things
and solve problems,
but are very broad in the
humanities and the arts
and in the social sciences,
and within various activities
and the strengths in athletics.
And it's, I think, quite
surprising for those
who come here as students,
even, and then also
as faculty and as staff to
absorb the culture as is.
JONES: The class that
entered in 1970, we
admitted 40% of
that applicant pool,
and this particular
class I mentioned
that you see in front of
you, the Class of 2005.
We admitted 18% of them.
So it's a very different
kind of a caliber of student
in the applicant pool.
The students entering in
'70 had 627-751 SAT scores.
627-751.
And I'll remind you that this
class has 711-756 SAT scores.
ROSKO: And we just saw the
principals, the marshals
from the graduate division,
going to the stage,
and I believe the
ceremony is about to begin
with Dana Mead, the
Chairman of the Corporation.
We thank you for joining
us, and we now turn it over.
Once again, I'm Tom
Rosko, and this was--
JONES: Marilee Jones.
Enjoy.
ROSKO: Enjoy the ceremony.
Thank you.
MEAD: Good morning.
The Corporation and the faculty
of the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology are now
declared convened,
together with this
assembly, on the occasion
of the commencement
exercises at this institution
for the conferring
of its degrees.
The stage assembly
and the audience
will please rise for the
invocation by Swami Tyagananda,
and remain standing
to join the MIT
Chorallaries in the singing
of one verse of the Star
Spangled Banner.
TYAGANANDA: Swami
Vivekananda once
said, "Education is the
manifestation of the perfection
already within us."
Our challenge is to transform
knowledge into wisdom,
and this is best achieved in
an environment that promotes
both unity and harmony.
I will recite now, first
in Sanskrit and then
in English translation,
an ancient prayer that
invokes this harmony.
[RECITING IN SANSKRIT]
May we come together
for a common purpose.
May our minds be of one accord.
Let us join our thoughts
for integrated wisdom.
Common be our prayer,
common our goal.
Common be our purpose,
common our desires.
Unified be our hearts.
United be our intentions.
Perfect be the unity
amongst us all.
Let me leave you now
with this prayer.
May the one and the
same divine being--
who is the father in
heaven of the Christians,
holy one of the Jewish
faith, Allah of the Muslims,
Buddha of the Buddhists,
Tao of the Chinese faith,
Ahura Mazda of the
Zoroastrians, the great spirit
of the Native Americans,
and Brahman of the Hindus--
lead us from ignorance
to knowledge,
from darkness to light,
from death to immortality.
May we be granted clear
understanding and the courage
to pursue our goals of social
justice, nonviolence, harmony,
and peace, with
single-minded attention.
[RECITING IN SANSKRIT]
Peace, peace, peace be unto all.
[MUSIC - "STAR SPANGLED BANNER"]
(SINGING) Oh say can you see,
by the dawn's early light, what
so proudly we hailed at the
twilight's last gleaming, whose
broad stripes and bright stars
through the perilous fight,
o'er the ramparts we watched,
were so gallantly streaming?
And the rockets' red glare,
the bombs bursting in air,
gave proof through the night
that our flag was still there.
Oh say, does that star-spangled
banner yet wave o'er
the land of the free and
the home of the brave?
[APPLAUSE]
MEAD: Please be seated.
I'm pleased to welcome the
honorable Michael A. Sullivan,
Mayor of the City of
Cambridge to our stage.
And I'm also pleased to welcome
the members of our 50th reunion
class, the distinguished
Class of 1955.
Now, it is my pleasure to
introduce our commencement
speaker--
Dr. Irwin M. Jacobs.
His distinguished biography
is included in your programs.
Dr. Jacobs is one of
MIT's most illustrious
and successful graduates,
whose leadership
of the telecommunications
industry, his advocacy
of science and math education,
and his philanthropy
in education and the arts,
are inspiring and in the best
tradition of MIT.
Ladies and gentlemen,
distinguished guests,
graduates, and graduates
to be, Dr. Irwin Jacobs.
JACOBS: Thank you very much.
It's a great honor
to be here with you
on this very special occasion.
And I would like to
give special thanks
to President Susan
Hockfield for asking
me to provide this address.
I'd also like to congratulate
the Class of 2005
on this very special
day, and provide
welcome to the family and
friends of the graduates,
to the faculty here, to
the entire MIT family.
It really indeed is
a very special time.
It's a very great
day to graduate.
I remember back to my receiving
my graduate degrees here--
a master's and a doctorate--
back in '57 and '59,
quite a few years ago,
fitting very well in with
the 50-year reunion class.
I must say that, at that
time, I could not possibly
have imagined all of
the things that we're
going to happen in my life
over the succeeding years.
And that indeed is something
I'd like to pick as the theme
today.
Namely, that we are all
going to-- and in particular
you're going to--
be going through a
great deal of change,
providing both opportunities
and occasionally some problems,
but that, in fact, an MIT
education is about the best
possible way to
prepare yourselves
for this very exciting future.
I suspect again that
a few years from now,
you'll have the opportunity to
think back over the many things
that you just could
not have anticipated,
and so it's important
to be prepared.
Be prepared for those changes.
My life itself has been
a number of changes.
I'll use those for an example.
I actually was born in New
Bedford, Massachusetts,
not too far from here.
When I graduated high school,
I had always been interested
in math and chemistry, physics.
My high school counselor
advised me that there was--
and this was 1950-- that there
was no future in science,
nor in engineering.
[LAUGHTER]
And since I didn't really have
a measure to evaluate that,
I then took his advice.
My family had a
small restaurant,
and so I entered the School
of Hotel Administration
at Cornell University.
Well, I had an
engineer as a roommate.
After a year and a half of
hearing him talk about--
you couldn't possibly
get those grades
if you were in
engineering-- and knowing I
really preferred
engineering, again,
I made a very significant
change in life,
and decided to transfer over
to electrical engineering.
And that was a very
exciting period.
I was a co-op student.
That turned out
to be very useful.
One of the engineers
I worked with then
advised me to go on
to graduate school,
and that's how I
ended up at MIT.
But thinking back, in my
last term at Cornell--
and this is how fast
things have changed--
I took a course in the theory
and practice, building,
of vacuum tubes.
Built a 6SN7, a 6J6--
you probably never even heard
of these terms any longer.
I was reminded last week, when
I gave a talk at the Computer
Museum in Mountain
View, and that, in fact,
has a lot of equipment that
originally came from a Computer
Museum here in
Boston, but now is out
in Mountain View, California.
And so, as I toured around
looking at all the equipment,
seeing analog and digital
differential analyzers up
to cell phones, which of
course are the latest and most
powerful computers--
I'll come back to that--
that, it was amazing to me
how fast things have changed.
And again, that's the
key issue with change.
It was amazing to see all
these familiar items that
had been in my life and then
passed out of it so quickly.
Well, I did decide to
apply and, luckily,
was accepted here at
MIT to graduate school.
I originally came
thinking that EM theory,
ElectroMagnetic theory would
be an interesting area.
But MIT, at that time,
Professor Claude Shannon
had just come, the father
of information theory,
there was a lot of
interest in the theory,
the mathematics, probability
theory, et cetera.
And so I decided that
that would be my future,
and very pleased
with that decision.
One of the early
courses I took was
from Professor Norbert Wiener.
Now, I don't think
probably anyone here
might have had the opportunity.
But it was very interesting.
There are many tales, I'm
sure, still running around
MIT about Professor Wiener.
One that I most remember,
in taking this class--
probably like several of the
classes you might have taken--
the lectures were-- well,
I shouldn't say this.
Probably, it's not
the case anymore.
But the lectures were
incomprehensible.
And so each night, a
group of graduate students
would get together
and try to figure out
what it was we had
heard during the day
and kind of put it together in
a way that we could understand.
About halfway through the
term, Professor Wiener
heard that we were doing this,
came to the room and said,
can I look at the material?
Became interested-- said we
should make a book from this.
And so we, then, continued
to put the material together
as a book.
He would come in,
every day after class,
and his only question was
how many pages are we up to?
So he always had a
different slant on things.
That book did come out.
It's Nonlinear Problems
in Random Theory.
It was the first book that
I was ever involved with.
Went on the faculty
here, again, it's
a wonderful way--
if some of you are
considering careers in teaching,
I'd greatly recommend it.
It's the best way
to learn material.
And while here, decided with
Professor Jack Wozencraft
to put together a textbook for
a senior-level communications
course on applying what was
then brand new digital theory
and information theory and try
to give it a little bit more
of a practical face.
And there were
many, at the time,
that said that there really
is no practical use for this.
You should just treat it
as applied mathematics.
In fact, of course,
that's turned out not
to be the case at all.
I did take a leave of absence to
make my one visit to California
about the time we were
finishing the book in '64, '65.
We decided that might be a
good place to retire some time,
came back to Boston, had a call
from a professor from Cornell
saying he's going
out to start a brand
new department of electrical
university in San Diego.
Would we join them?
First reaction, of
course, was no--
family, friends, career here.
But after a couple
of days, we decided
that California and a
brand new university,
an opportunity for a
different experience
might be quite exciting in
our lives, and we accepted.
Again, change-- the change from
here to a brand new school.
It was interesting.
A brand new school-- it
was very small, of course,
very few faculty.
One of the classes I started
had to do with introduction
to computer science.
There were some
engineering students.
But there were
students and faculty
from music and from
the arts departments,
and in interacting with them,
developed even a greater
love and appreciation for
the arts and for music
that we've been able to
follow, then, ever since.
It was very interesting being
in a brand new university.
But that also led to another
major change in my life.
Because of the MIT
background, a lot of industry
in Southern
California, there were
many requests for consulting.
Typically, if you're
in the faculty,
you might consult a day a week.
And so I mentioned that to a
couple of friends from UCLA
and the faculty of UCLA as we
were flying back on a trip.
And they said let's start a
company and share consulting.
And I said fine,
as long as I don't
have to get involved
with managing it.
And so we started our first
company called Linkabit.
And very quickly
it began to grow.
And so I did, then,
decide to take a year off
and check out business, try to
get things properly organized.
Didn't know, really,
a thing about it.
Luckily, in the Hotel
School I had had a course
in accounting, a course
in business law--
so a little bit of background
turned out to be very useful.
But really had to learn the
business side of things.
Engineering is, by far,
the best preparation
for just about any field.
So that has indeed
worked out very well.
Well, Linkabit, this first
company did grow very nicely.
We got involved in a number
of interesting programs--
one scrambling TV
signals from satellite
to home that's turned into a
very major business, another
what are called very small
aperture earth terminals for--
if you put a credit card
in at a gas station, often,
it will go over one of
these satellite terminals.
The first what's called
Time-Division, TDMA type
of cellular phone-- we got into
the cellular phone business
early on.
And actually a processor--
we didn't know the
name at the time,
and I don't think it was
really out-- but a reduced
instruction set
processor that we built
into a terminal for use
in government programs
and, in particular,
for a program
here at Lincoln Laboratory to
communicate with what was then
called the LES-8 -9 satellite.
So again, things tied
back together very nicely,
but very exciting to be
able to come up with ideas,
be able to apply theory
to things that were rather
practical, rather useful.
Well, we made the mistake, in a
sense, of selling that company.
And in 1985, I retired.
Retirement was a terrible thing.
So I lasted about three months
and then started Qualcomm.
And I very much assured my wife
that if things went very well,
we might have 100
employees at some time.
Put that in context, we're
now over 8,000 employees.
And by the way, in
my welcoming, I also
meant to welcome any
Qualcomm shareholders that
might be here today.
Well, we didn't
have any products.
Luckily, we didn't have to
go out for venture capital,
so we didn't have to
have a business plan.
But we knew digital.
We knew wireless would
be very exciting.
And it turned out that
it was on a drive down
from a consulting contract
meeting in Los Angeles.
A drive down the San Diego,
about halfway, luckily--
it's 110 miles or so--
about halfway down, realized
that something called
Code-Division
Multiple Access, CDMA
would be very useful for
mobile communications.
Well, the company
was very small.
We had to wait a few
years before we could
go ahead and develop that idea.
But the time came when we
sold our first product,
had a little bit of
a cash flow, and were
able to, then, go
back and pay attention
to CDMA, actually,
at the end of 1988
began to take a look at it.
Well, if any of you decide to
go into you own businesses--
and some of you I'm sure
we'll be doing that--
you run across a
time when you have
to make a
bet-the-company decision.
And so CDMA was one of those.
Should you put a lot of money
into R&D in a technology that
may or may not be accepted?
The world is going off
in a different direction.
And luckily, at
that time, I had not
heard one of the
projections that
had been made to AT&T by a
consultant a few years earlier
that, if all went well,
there might be 1 million cell
phones in use by the year 2000.
Actually, they missed
by a little bit.
It was 600 million.
And that, of course,
gave a great opportunity
for moving ahead with CDMA.
We did develop the
technology, demonstrated--
because otherwise, everything
sounds too complicated.
You have to have
a demonstration.
So that was, again, one of the
bet-your-company-type issues.
And then the question
comes up, if you now
have a good product, how do
you build a business model?
What do you do about that?
And so again, this
is a type of concern
that you may be
having going forward.
We decided to go into a mode,
which was both licensing
and of selling, initially,
phones and infrastructure
to get things started,
but, ultimately, the chips.
And that works out very well.
As you know, chips keep
getting more and more powerful.
You can put more and
more capability in them.
If you come up with
innovative ideas,
you can build those
into the chips.
And so that's exactly the
path that we followed.
It's interesting
that, today, there's
probably about 1 and 1/2
billion users of cell
phones around the world.
In 2005, there were over 600
million sold in the one year,
or will be by the
end of the year.
Comparing that to about 150
million desktop and laptop
computers, it's quite clear that
the future is not in plastics,
but really, now,
in mobile devices.
And the interesting aspect
is that the capabilities
keep going up.
One of the things that
is now being provide
is what's called
third generation.
I won't, again, go into details.
But if some of you have been
using, not just the wireless
that's available on campus--
that's called 802.11,
but a wide area coverage
provided right now
by Verizon here,
one can get a very
high data rate
anywhere that you can
receive a cell phone call.
And so that is a key step.
But the interesting
part is the devices.
And because of Moore's law, the
number of transistors on a chip
doubling roughly every
two years or so--
power going down,
costs going down,
all the right things
kind of happening--
there's been a major
transformation.
When we first built up
our first cell phone,
it took three chips to implement
the communications only.
Now it takes about
20% of one chip.
What do you do
with the other 80%?
You can put a lot
of computing power.
In fact, now we're
going to two processes--
one of which is moving toward
a gigahertz-type processing
speed.
Two processes, a couple of
signal processing units, a 3D
graphics capability,
GPS receiving--
you can put a lot on
that chip, make it
available at a low
cost, high reliability,
and therefore very
useful to people.
Therefore, since it's a computer
now, not really a phone--
you may not realize it when
you're carrying it around--
very powerful computer that
opens up many possibilities.
And so we developed another
approach we call ROO.
In fact, there's a conference
now with about 2,400 people
at it occurring in San Diego--
where developers
anywhere in the world
can develop an application to
be downloaded to the phone.
We arranged to provide a
digital signature, tested
digital signature so it
won't corrupt the phone.
And therefore, they can
develop these, bring them
via some internet meeting
grounds we've established
with the operators,
bring their applications
to the attention of
operators around the world,
and build the business.
And I think, at
this meeting that's
ongoing, it was mentioned that
there was about $350 million
that had been funneled from
operators to Qualcomm, then
Qualcomm back to the
developers around the world,
in this last six months, in
the order of $150 million.
The more exciting
aspect is other things
I think that were going to
be able to do with that.
We've all heard of issues with
the digital divide, access
to communications, to the
internet being more limited
in certain regions.
I think that the phone
as a low-cost device
with a huge amount
of computing power,
connection to the internet,
ability to download software,
process-- it had a large
amount of memory by the way.
With the appropriate amount
of thinking and planning
can be used to supplement
teaching in many remote areas
as well as, of course, developed
areas around the world.
So I think that there's a great
possibility there to move ahead
with these devices.
People are still just realizing
what the power in the devices
might be.
And again, hopefully,
some of you
out there will find
this challenging.
Of course there's
also medical devices
that are now being
attached to the cell phone
measuring blood capabilities
and moving toward eGovernment
providing support, voting,
information, et cetera by use
of the cell phone.
So again, a device we
think of as a phone,
very powerful computer,
opening lots of opportunities.
Well, I mentioned eGovernment--
one of the things I would like
to recommend to all of you,
at least some of
you is to think--
well, all of you to
think about politics.
To some of you, perhaps, to
consider a career in politics.
Again, I think an MIT
education prepares you
for just about anything.
And it was interesting.
It was over a couple of years
ago-- so the previous president
of China, we had a meeting.
They always have
this very formal U.
So myself and the president was
sitting at the head of the U
and then staff is
on either side.
And there's a little
bit of chit chat
that occurs before
the formal meeting.
What do you think
the first question
that was raised by the president
of China sitting next to me?
How many more generations did I
think Moore's law had to run--
president of China.
Discussing it with
him a little further,
it turned out he actually
was trained as an engineer,
as a radio engineer, as was
the prime minister at the time.
That's the kind of
interest and ability
to, again, think
about technology,
bring it to use that I
think is also very important
here in this country.
And of course, there's very
little of that available here.
Another aspect, when I
came to be a student here,
I was lucky to benefit
from the Research
Laboratory of Electronics,
but it was very well
funded at the time.
Now, the funding has been
cut back quite a bit.
There really are reasons to get
out, to become very politically
active.
Well, there have
been many rewards
from having this
type of an education.
Being able to go out--
the world is changing.
One can take advantage of
those changes, do very well.
It's important, of course,
to have an impact back.
And the opportunity for
philanthropy, of course,
never goes away.
We've been very lucky.
Our focus often is on
education, but also
cultural activities, other
activities around the world.
And I think, again,
that's something that,
as you begin to move
ahead in your careers,
that you should definitely
pay attention to.
So I'd would like to finish
by, again, congratulating you.
You're embarking on
a great adventure.
You're probably entering a
period where there's even
greater change, greater things
happening around the world
than was correct when
I graduated here.
You might have seen the
statement back from 1899
that the head of
the patent office
said that everything that can
be invented has been invented.
Clearly, another
shortsighted statement.
But if you check with
the patent office now,
you'll find that many of
the applications, many
of the patents in
the US patent office
are coming from overseas.
And so again, the
competition is heightened.
We have to move ahead.
We have to improve our
education throughout.
We have to remain
very innovative.
You can certainly be
guaranteed that there
will be there changes.
You have been well-prepared.
I wish you as much
fun and excitement
as I have had along the way.
Than you all very much.
[APPLAUSE]
PRESENTER: Thank you
so much Dr. Jacobs
for a very interesting
and perceptive glimpse
into the future and the
challenges, and I should say,
the promise that it holds
for MIT's graduates.
Thank you so much.
And now, Mr. Barun Singh,
President of the Graduate
Student Council will
give a salute to MIT
from the graduate student body.
And following this,
Mr. Rohit Gupte,
president of the senior class
will present the class gift
to President Hockfield, after
which the president will
deliver her charge
to the graduates.
Barun?
SINGH: My fellow engineers,
scientists, humanists,
sociologists, artists, creators,
inventors, philosophers,
designers, planners,
entrepreneurs, leaders,
architects of the future, and
friends, you gather here today
in triumph.
And to you have come the spoils
of years of rigorous commitment
and dedication.
For this day, this
graduation day
from these prestigious halls,
of this grand Institute
of Technology, this
day belongs to you.
We live in a universe
defined by contrast.
And all of your struggles
during your time
here define the sheer beauty
and joy of this moment.
I'm sure that, as you
walk through today
in the celebration
of your success,
you will relish the
magnitude of what
you have gained during your time
here in your journey thus far--
the encyclopedic knowledge
you have accumulated,
the invaluable assortment
of relationships
that you have built, the
amazing uniqueness of activities
you have participated
in, and, of course,
the massive amounts of
free pizza you've consumed.
In all reality,
what I hope you'll
relish the most is the
growth you have experienced
within yourself, not teachable
from the world around you,
yet necessitated by those
very requirements which
have led you to this point.
I offer you the words of
Sir Edmund Hillary who,
along with Nepalese
shirpa Tenzing Norgay,
became the first person
on record to have climbed
the heights of Mount Everest.
Reflecting upon his
trying experience,
Hillary stated, "It
is not the mountain
we conquer, but ourselves."
Today, you stand here
having climbed the heights
to the roof of the
world of academia
and so have also
conquered yourselves.
You have tested and
stretched your limits.
You have learned to persist
in the face of pressure
and self-doubt and
difficulty, and that is where
the true congratulations lie.
There are a number
of people today
who take part in the celebration
of your achievements--
your parents,
mentors, advisors who
have taught you, who have
inspired you and supported you
so that you could be here today.
Your friends,
family, and peers who
have grown right alongside you,
all of the students, faculty,
staff, alumni, and
community members
who, in playing their
own individual roles,
make this Institute what
it is and, therefore, share
in some part of your success.
In recognizing their impact
on your own development,
I hope that you can
recognize that you will soon
find yourselves in their shoes.
And I invite you to
act as the mentors
and inspirational voices for
the classes yet to follow.
Beyond the solidification
of your own ability
to live and thrive in this
world, however, all of us
here today celebrate
something far greater.
We celebrate the hope
and promise and potential
that you represent for
the future of time to come
and for the world we all share.
As you talk with people about
your graduation from MIT,
no doubt they will
ask you if you
are ready for this thing
they call the real world, as
if something about your time at
MIT had been unreal, imagined,
just the dream.
And don't you wish
that dream could
have taken place on
a nice tropical beach
somewhere instead?
And yet, there is some
truth to what they say.
Because as you begin the
next leg of your journey,
outside of this
environment, you will likely
find yourself in a very
different sort of a world--
a world where reason
increasingly takes a back stage
to rhetoric, a world where fear
is fast becoming the norm while
curiosity and the search
for scientific advancement
grow ever more suspect.
At the same time,
it is a world where
the problems that confront us--
poverty, disease,
corruption, war, famine,
environmental depletion--
have consequences far greater
than that of any problem set.
And in this real world, you
must be the agents of change.
You must be the leaders,
for you have demonstrated
a mastery of that one
most essential skill not
to be underestimated--
the ability
to think, to reason, to consider
the global and the long term,
and not just the here and now.
These words may seem
hollow at first.
After all, you walk into this
world, but an individual.
You face problems,
many of which,
have confronted mankind
for generations.
Yet, I ask you, who will define
the status quo of the world
to come if not you?
Gandhi, a man who knew
something of the strength
and power of the one in the
face of the many once said,
"We must be the change
we wish to see."
This quote holds relevance
for all of us here.
For those of you who have truly
found paradise during your stay
here at MIT, in participating
in the meritocratic ideal,
in displaying that trademark
intellectual defiance,
in exercising your passion
to debate and delve
into the heart of
things, and your refusal
to accept what is handed
to you, and in being
open to the most
unconventional of solutions
to the most hopeless
of problems--
to you, I say, and I
charge to you today
to keep alive that
passion and drive.
The world needs it.
And it waits for you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
GUPTE: Since the beginning
of our life journey,
we have dreamed of becoming
seekers of knowledge.
We are a generation
that did not directly
witness the mission to
the moon or the marches
for civil rights like
our mothers and fathers.
We are inspired by the
information age, spawned
in our basements,
and most symbolically
represented by the internet.
The difference is significant.
While our parents could
watch the Apollo missions
with awe and envy, their
immediate participation
in the growth of these important
world changes was limited.
We, on the other hand, have
been gifted with the opportunity
to participate in global changes
in an unprecedented fashion.
We live in a world where
technology has been focused
on the public for
everyday living,
not just for specialized
military or government use.
Technology has never been more
applied to the broad population
like it is today.
And we have embraced it in
all the value that it brings.
Since we were
surrounded, many of us
found our curious minds trying
to learn what it is all about.
We opened up computers,
we built robots,
we performed
research experiments
long before we arrived at MIT.
This world we live in
now, with applications
of technology everywhere
before our eyes,
fits seamlessly with
MIT's academic goals.
The time and energy we have
spent in laboratories, classes,
UROPs, and the unprecedented
number out-of-classroom
learning opportunities
have culminated
to form the experience
we call MIT.
And yet, our formal
training is only
a part of what we carry
away from our time here.
The relationships
that we have formed
within our community and
the way that we have learned
to learn in such an intense
and rich environment
has created the most
lasting impact on us.
Our experiences at
MIT can be compared
to, ironically, a vacation.
Imagine you went on a vacation
to an unfamiliar place
and encountered, perhaps,
the worst possible weather.
If you had your closest
friends with you, together,
you would still find a way
to have a fantastic time.
Well, the same works at MIT.
Is the people with whom we
have spent our years here
that make this place amazing
and allow us to succeed.
Together we have
done more than if we
summed our individual efforts.
Together we have
grown more wise.
As this community
diverges and integrates
into the larger society, we
will never forget the union.
Forever are we attached.
We have become citizens of a
nation, a nation called MIT.
We share with our
brothers and sisters
an immediate connection.
When you meet someone and
hear that she went to MIT,
you already understand
so much more
about what she's been through.
Hear of an MIT grad,
and immediately you
sense the awesomeness of
his intellectual drive
and his accomplishments
thus far.
For to have graduated
from MIT is no easy feat.
Yet, we remain
humbled as we recall
our difficult experiences.
It is in these testing
moments that we
can see the opportunities
that allow us to put
our experiences to good use.
However, as members of
this marvelous citizenry,
there comes a duty.
With our citizenship
of the MIT nation,
we must understand the
incredible responsibility
of holders of this great
power called knowledge.
For the world will look at
us and our patent disregard
for doing the normal.
The world will look at us for
our audacity and our courage
to question everything
we see around us.
The world will look to us,
and it is our responsibility
to look back at them
and say, together
we can accomplish anything.
Oliver Wendell Holmes once
said, "What lies behind us
and what lies before us
are tiny matters compared
to what lies within us."
What we have
accomplished here at MIT,
the education,
the relationships,
the community is by
no means trivial.
But what we truly
take away from MIT
is the way that these
experiences have changed us.
This is what we
bring to our future.
Let us go forth and
show them who we are.
And now please join
me as we partake
in the tradition of the
turning of our brass rat
as a symbol of our
accomplishments.
[CHEERING]
At this time it is
my distinct honor
to request President Susan
Hockfield to join me as we
present the senior class gift.
In keeping with the traditions
of improving student life,
the class of 2005 has
designated their class gift
towards the creation
of a new student lounge
to take the place of the
cashier's office in Lobby 10
right behind me.
This year, we were
able to raise over
$31,000 with 25.4%
participation.
Congratulations.
And thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
HOCKFIELD: Thank
you, Barun, and thank
you Rohit, and the members
of the class of 2005
for your gift.
The new student lounge
off the Lobby 10
will provide a welcome
space for students
to come together at the
heart of a very busy campus.
It will create a
space for conversation
and for collaboration.
And thank you Irwin Jacobs for
your thoughtful and inspiring
remarks.
Your work and your
life are evidence
of a mind that has thought
far into the future
to explore the expanding
promise and power of technology
to improve our lives.
The Institute is
honored to count you
as an alumnus and a friend.
Graduates of MIT,
this is your day.
We have gathered here
today in Killeen Court
to celebrate your
accomplishments,
the successful completion of
demanding courses of study,
often, lasting several years.
You have our deepest respect for
all that you have accomplished.
But today is not yours alone.
None of you would
be here this morning
were it not for the
family and friends
who have nurtured and
supported you since childhood.
Those people who have
embraced your dreams
and lighted your path--
this is their day too.
Graduates, I ask you
please to rise and join
with me in thanking
those family and friends.
[APPLAUSE]
A month ago, I stood
here in Killeen Court
and spoke about what defines
MIT, about my dreams and hopes
for this great institution.
Those inaugural
remarks were addressed
to the whole
Institute community.
This morning, I
would like to speak
to those of you who
are graduating today
about my hopes and
dreams for you.
You, our graduates, are
exceptional individuals.
You arrived at MIT with
remarkable native talents
already honed by years
of demanding study.
Here, you've learned
from a brilliant faculty,
and just as important,
from each other.
You've learned about
complex subject matter,
and you've also learned
about yourselves.
Now, as you leave
MIT, I challenge
you to put what you
have learned here
to work for the good of
this nation and the world
because we have never needed
your talents and skills more
than we do now.
We live in uncertain
and an unsettled age,
and we face great challenges.
To name only a few--
we have challenges in
energy, in climate change,
in contagious
diseases, in the design
of our urban communities,
and in global poverty.
You, the graduates of
MIT, are uniquely equipped
to address issues like these.
You are ready to make the
necessary advances in science
and technology to employ
rigorous quantitative and
qualitative analyses
to develop new methods
of interdisciplinary
inquiry and problem-solving.
So at times, in the years ahead,
when a choice of direction
presents itself, I hope
you will ask yourselves,
where can I do the most good?
How can I make a
difference in the world?
Now, you will not be able
to do this work alone.
Meeting the great
challenges of our era
will require teamwork
and collaboration.
You will need to
draw, not only on what
you have learned in the
classroom and laboratory,
but also on what you have
learned about the importance
of community.
As the currents of your
lives draw you away
from MIT's shores, you will,
in important and real ways,
remain part of this community.
At the close of this
morning's ceremonies,
Linda Sharpe, President
of the Alumni Association
will formally welcome you into
the Association's membership.
We hope you will stay
connected and engaged
with the life of the Institute.
But beyond your own
personal connection to MIT,
I hope you will also
transmit the values
that define this community to
the other communities you will
now join, that you will see
leadership as an opportunity
to serve the common good,
that you will make integrity
the touchstone of
your judgments,
that you will exemplify
the pursuit of truth
and an unwavering drive
toward excellence,
and that you will
continue to demonstrate
the value of plain
old-fashioned hard work.
Finally, and perhaps
most crucially,
I ask you to inspire your own
generation and those to come
with a renewed sense of
possibility and optimism
for the future.
Here at MIT, we see, up
close, the myriad ways
in which science and technology
promise to benefit humankind.
If we are to realize
that promise,
we need to kindle in others the
same love and passion for truth
and discovery, for creativity
and problem-solving that
brought us all here.
I hope that each of you will
embrace this as your challenge.
I would not set you this
charge if I did not think
that each of you could meet it.
I have tremendous faith in you.
The intelligence,
diligence, and creativity
you've demonstrated here at
MIT have inspired us all.
And I know that, in the years
to come, you will do even more
and surprise and delight
us with achievements
we could never have predicted.
So for now, in
closing, let me simply
say congratulations
graduates of MIT.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank you,
President Hockfield,
for your first charge
to the graduates
as the 16th president of MIT.
And now, the presentation
of the degrees.
By virtue of the authority
delegated to them
by the Corporation
of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology,
and upon recommendation
of the faculty, President
Hockfield and Provost Brown
will now present the degrees.
President Hockfield will
present the following degrees--
Bachelor of Science, Bachelor
of Science/Master of Science,
Bachelor of Science/Master
of Engineering,
and the advanced
degrees for the School
of Science and Whitaker
College of Health Sciences
and Technology.
Provost Brown will present
the advanced degrees
for the School of
Architecture and Planning,
the School of Engineering, the
School of Humanities, Arts,
and Social Sciences, and the
Sloan School of Management.
As they approach the ramp,
[CHEERING]
undergraduate degree recipients
will be greeted
by the chancellor,
the dean for student
life, and the dean
for undergraduate education.
Graduate degree
recipients will be
greeted by their school deans.
The first graduates
to be recognized
are the class marshals who
are seated on the stage.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
SPEAKER: Recognition
will now be given
to the offices of
the class of 2005
and the offices of the
Graduate Student Council
who are seated on the stage.
[READING NAMES]
SPEAKER: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of
Architecture and Planning
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
[READING NAMES]
SPEAKER: Bachelor
of Science diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of
Architecture and planning
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
diplomas will now
be presented to students in
the School of Engineering
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
[READING NAMES]
SPEAKER: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of Engineering
who have completed the specified
degree requirements.
[READING NAMES]
SPEAKER: Bachelor
of Science diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of Humanities,
Arts and Social Sciences
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
[READING NAMES]
SPEAKER: Bachelor
of Science diplomas
will now be presented
to students in the Sloan
School of Management who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
[READING NAMES]
SPEAKER: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of
Humanities, Arts,
and Social Sciences who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
[READING NAMES]
SPEAKER: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be presented
to students in the Sloan
School of Management who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
[READING NAMES]
SPEAKER: Bachelor
of Science diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of Science who
have completed the specified
degree requirements.
[READING NAMES]
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
SPEAKER: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of Science who
have completed the specified
degree requirements.
[READING NAMES]
SPEAKER: The Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institution
and the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
offer joint programs of
education and research
in oceanography and applied
ocean science and engineering.
John W. Farrington, Vice
President for Academic Programs
and Dean at the Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institution
is here to participate
with President Hockfield
in awarding the
following joint degrees.
[READING NAMES]
SPEAKER: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be presented to
students in the Whitaker
College of Health
Sciences and Technology
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
[READING NAMES]
SPEAKER: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of
Architecture and Planning
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
[READING NAMES]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Graduates,
congratulations.
It's now my pleasure
to introduce
Linda Sharpe, the Chief Marshal
who will greet the graduates.
Miss Sharpe is a member
of the class of 1969
and is currently serving as the
president of the Association
of Alumni and Alumnae of MIT--
Linda.
SHARPE: It is my honor to
recognize the distinguished
class of 2005, the
newest alumni of MIT.
The entire--
[CHEERING]
The entire alumni body, now,
some 110,000-strong joins me
in congratulating all of the
2005 graduates and officially
welcoming you into
the alumni family,
your infinite connection to MIT.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: At the
conclusion, a reception
will follow on Kresge Oval
in the West Campus Plaza.
Now, I'd like to ask the
group to stand and join
the MIT chorallaries in
singing the school song.
[MUSIC - MIT CHORALLARIES,
"ARISE ALL YE OF MIT"]
CHORALLARIES: (SINGING)
Arise all ye of MIT,
in loyal fellowship.
The future beckons unto ye,
and life is full and rich.
Arise and raise
your glass on high.
Tonight shall ever
be a memory that
will never die for ye of MIT.
Thy sons and daughters, MIT,
return from far and wide.
And gather here once more to
be renourished by thy side.
And as we raise our glasses high
to pledge our love for thee,
we join all those of days
gone by in praise of MIT.
[CHEERING]
[MUSIC - MIT CHORALLARIES, "TAKE
ME BACK TO TECH"]
CHORALLARIES:
(SINGING) Oh, I wish
that I were back again at Tech
on Boylston Street, dressed
in my dinky uniform
so dapper and so neat.
I'm crazy after calculus.
I never had enough.
It was hard to be
dragged away so young.
It was horribly, awfully tough.
Hurrah for technology,
-ology, -ology, oh.
Glorious old technology,
-ology, ology, oh.
Back in the days that were free
from care in the 'ology varsity
shop, with nothing to do but
analyze air in an anemometrical
top--
the differentiation of
the trigonometric powers,
the constant pi
that made me sign
in those happy days of ours.
Hoorah, for technology,
-ology, -ology, oh.
Glorious old technology,
Take me back on a special train
to the glorious Institute,
I yearn for the inspiration
of a technological toot.
Toot-toot.
I'd shun the quizzical, physical
profs, the chapel and all that.
But how I'd love to go
again on a scientific bat.
La, la, la la, la, la la, la,
la la, la, la la, la, la la,
la, la la, la, la la, la,
la, la la, la, la la,
ta da, ta, da, ta, da, ta, da,
ta, dum, ta, dum, ta, dum, ta,
dum--
Oh, M-A-S-S-A-C-H-U-S-E-T-T-S
I-N-S-T-I-T-U-T-E-O-F-T-E
and then, it's C-H-N-O-L-O-G
and Y, comes after G,
it's the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
Hey!
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - "AULD LANG SYNE"]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC - "SEMPER FIDELIS"]
[MUSIC - "THE ARENA"]